Pretty much alive.
Mm-hmm.
Well, I don't know if I'm alive.
I'm losing it right now.
Oh, shit.
Oh, yeah, because you're sick right now.
I got the cold of, like, my lifetime.
I don't know what happened.
No.
Oh, that sucks.
It's okay.
I'm going to recover.
I'm trying to do the boogie right now for us.
You should start organizing.
I'm excited.
We too have wanted to play this game.
I've been seeing, like, 5 million clips of this on my
Twitter.
feed like like it's blowing up and i was like i wish i
should play this game i was like i'm seeing it everywhere i
should finally play this game i have floating matara on the
corner of my screen and i don't know where this word's
coming from i you're just floating in the world why are you
just floating in the corner matara i'm trying to make it
easier she's she is happily in the group with me there's
like where's this i can't find the source i don't know where
it's coming from it's i live here like none of the sources
are on this is weird okay i'm ghost haunted i'm like haunted
but it goes to matara's fugi i'm not even dead yet but i'm
already pre-haunting you yeah i'm just like where is this
where is this fugi coming from not too not to be what's the
word morbid but in eastern european culture we have this
thing that like if you start dreaming about your
grandparents or stuff like that it means they're going to
die soon so this is like i'm going to die from this cold and
i'm already haunting you yeah oh yeah oh yeah mecha mecha
chameleon does have in-game voice chat just everyone knows
um it does yeah yeah oh have you played the in-game voice i
feel like we should because then it'd be like We'd be
baiting the hider when they're like not even in the same
room.
Isn't that the best?
I was like, oh, you're getting...
I mean, we could if you guys want to.
All right, we'll bait the hide.
Yeah, we'll bait the seeker.
Be like, oh, you're so close to me.
And he's like 20 miles away.
It's the torment of people giggling.
Oh, true.
The speaker have no idea why.
It's like the paranoia.
Like, they could be anywhere.
Hey, Snuffy.
Hey, Snoppy.
Hi, Snoppy.
Hi, gang.
What's up?
I still don't know.
I'm trying to find where this source is coming from from
Atari.
And I, like, closed every source.
No, keep me there.
But she's still there.
She's just there.
I just don't know what to do.
I'll show you guys.
Oh, yeah.
For those who don't know, Mint is currently stuck somewhere
doing a work assignment.
And she won't tell us what it is.
She doesn't.
She doesn't trust us enough to not leak the NDA.
Yep.
Can you guys believe this?
Dude, my theory is Minches got casted in the next Marvel
movie.
She's the next Avengers.
You will see her in a dude.
She will return in Doomsday.
Is there like a ghost adventure?
A ghost adventure.
Ghost rider.
There's ghost rider.
She stole Nicholas Cage's role that's fucked up, then.
It's okay.
He asked Spider-Man.
Wait, Mitchell was hype.
He went for Spider-Man instead.
Yeah, yeah.
I feel like that's an upgrade.
I just drew it, and so let me do the mandatory chat.
Is everybody's volumes okay?
Oh, yeah, chat.
I've been adjusting, and some people, I can't get you high
enough, so I'm just, like, boosting and boosting.
Some people, I'm not going to name names.
Yeah, we're not going to name names.
Of course, nothing, but some people.
But some people.
Surprise me!
It is a little too quiet.
Just a little bit.
I can't put it up.
I'm sorry.
I can't put my volume up in here.
I had some headroom.
I've just maxed you out.
It's fine.
Oh, dang.
I'm not going to lie.
She does.
This is my first time hearing Nemi and Snuffy together.
And it feels like Charmellian.
Sorry, Charmander and Charmellian.
Like in the same...
Who is the evolution?
Yeah, who is the evolution?
I'm like, yeah, I think Snuffy, because Snuffy's just a
little rastier, but am I the only one hearing it, or is it
because I'm sick and I'm, like, congested?
Yeah, it's just, I mean, I don't think I've ever compared my
friends to Pokemon evolution before, it might be, it might
be like the fever cooking your head.
Wait, wait, wait, Mimi, say hi, I'm Snuffy, and the Snuffy
says, no, don't say that, don't say that, no, no, I feel
like I don't sound like you, hi, I'm Snuffy.
no guys don't hear it at all sometimes i don't think so she
trails higher i trail lower no it's up your turn your sir
say hi i'm mimi i feel like if i listened to you i could
maybe copy you okay i can take your skin hi i'm mimi hi i'm
mimi i'm yeah you guys for real can't hear it at all like
not even no i can hear it when nimi's trying to Yeah, I'm
sorry.
I think you might you took too many like, like, like two
weeks ago, right?
No, you and I got drunk together.
No, no.
We had our clothes off.
No, we had our clothes off.
We were I don't remember.
That's not good.
You know, like, we're like, we're going to bed with our
clothes off.
That's not good.
OK, I'm sorry.
I am kidding about the second part, but the first part, I
thought was for real um i think the second part wasn't
allowed you don't have to you don't have to hide i love i
think i'm just congested so like it's harder to hear i think
it's i think it's making you delirious it really is demented
delirious delusional i'm just gonna delete your food like
i'm just gonna delete your foodie from the source delete
don't be like hilarious get it i'm gonna delete matara con
from please don't be please what have i done remove matara
con maybe she'll disappear maybe she'll disappear that's
really messed up i'm still trying to figure out how to get
rid of you in the corner stop how could i put me at the
corner it's like i don't know why she's there i literally
removed every source but she's just haunting my obs for some
reason she literally looks like the live matara reaction
feeling matara i love it i'm trying to like change settings
for this game and none of them are like it's just ignoring
me it doesn't care it's classic every freaking game we ever
choose to play is some sort of horrendous like inaccessible
monster yeah no it's it's crazy it's just like yo i'm gonna
take the wrong resolution Wait, you want to change the
resolution?
No, you can't do that.
It's okay, fine.
Oh my God.
You quit up in the British for it too.
You were like, we can't do that.
It's impossible.
I don't think, I've never heard why I'm saying can't.
No, Kant is, Kant is a Britishism for me.
I can't say can't.
Oh, you can't convert.
That's cursed.
Maybe after three more years of streaming, it'll be
conditioned.
You just need three more.
You know, it's already been like, it's already been like
four years.
What's another?
Oh, yeah.
When you hit your 20th anniversary, that's all.
Today's the day.
One valve per year, man.
Let's go.
For your 20th anniversary, can we do like one of those like
big of like really fancy events like a wedding where we all
like rent out a barn and we do like a big.
Everybody.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Can we tape me to the ceiling?
It's the limo ball.
Can we tape me to the ceiling like they did in those like
land parties in the lake?
Yeah.
can do that yeah that's fine land party it's like this this
is where i want to be at line was 20th anniversary barn land
party oh this photo she's a roach on the walls it works
exactly exactly i'm just gonna refill my water one sec i've
got the game launched and everything all right uh we got
okay we got to start who wants to make this i guess i'd make
the server yes tell me all right it's all right guys i knew
i knew i had to make the server thank you mommy oh wait you
can adjust frame your fps i'm gonna go all in 200 frames she
locked in yeah 200 frames when i shoot you guys down yeah i
thought this was a deduction game you're still shooting you
like the parkour people were doing in magic amelia i want to
be surprised i want to be surprised emote in between when
you get caught so like people can miss the shot because
you're shooting at somewhere where they're emote oh wait
that's actually fun yeah no i've seen people like just
dodging shots no that's people better not run when i'm the
seeker because i can't even anticipate that as a mechanic is
that we have to like actually kill each other so it's just
become like
that's all you up your fps you're up the fps guys no no
that's how they get you i'm so ready okay i'm gonna try one
more attempt to give her the matara in the corner he is
resilient i am i actually don't get rid of a cockroach right
now welcome back thank you is this gonna be music or are we
just We're just making it.
No, it had music, but then it's like, it just stopped.
Like it just, yeah.
Like when you put it up, there was a little bit of music and
then the- Yeah, yeah, anything.
Do you see the captions when you hover over the options
here?
It's like, so you said, create server, let's get started.
Find server, let's find them.
Settings, set it up properly so it doesn't freeze.
And then quit game, I'll be waiting forever.
Oh, what?
Like when you mouse over quit game, there's just like a
little thing.
with a dude that just says i'll be waiting forever all right
okay let's see server name i'll do uh where is mint she's
the best hiderable she's actually here already painted we
just can't find her so apparently the password does show up
when i type it in so don't show the yeah i'm not i'm not
going to capture the game until we're there this is okay
this is the game the server name and the
Oh, I like it.
It's not a very secure password.
It's okay.
I also had max players on so nobody can sneak in.
No, I'm just sneaking in.
When we're all here, everything will be fine.
Wait, so we just enter server name and server password?
Yeah, and then password.
Oh, looking, looking, looking.
Also, no, it's a very secure password, guys.
at least 20 digits guys it it was so secure hello hello are
we in yeah i like how the in the sound is like this dancing
penguin if you look boot up the audio is this like what is
this graphical thing what is this like blur guys i'm hurting
ladies ladies i'm hurting oh my god we had you emoted r all
right okay it hurts oh my god wait there's no there's no
sensitivity oh wait there is okay i was gonna freak out it
was oh yeah i gotta do that too we're out here with like our
gaming mice for first-person shooters and then every game
you join is like oh this is too much we can't be sweating
met the chameleon no no listen i need the correct sense so i
can i can like 180 snipe you when i realize where you are
yeah exactly i gotta i'm practicing my dodges you see that
never played this game so i'm just running through the i'm
all the information i is from the all the clips i saw
bye-bye i haven't played that idea i think lab have you
played this game already no no no oh my god this is a game
that live has been played i know it's crazy Wait, we can
draw ourselves.
No, she's a gamer.
Are you implying that when we played that like that dueling
mage game, I had snuck in and practiced before the collab
started or something?
I'm not gonna say it.
Limerick was busy studying the blade while we were too busy
freaking goofing off.
Oh.
Yeah, before every collab...
Just downloaded every game ever made into my brain.
Yeah, before every collab, she like glabs it.
Like she does like a few and three hours.
He's a gamer.
Before showing up, I gotta draw myself.
Tari, what the fuck?
Yeah, true.
Why are you slouchy?
Also, it says BGM.
There's a credit for BGM.
I hear no BGM.
This game doesn't have to be.
I just think we just looped it.
Do girls think I would like look like I fit in?
I'm gonna steal this idea that I got from a dragon.
Oh, yeah, you can paint.
You can paint yourself.
Oh, God.
Oh, Jesus.
This is far too complicated.
Is there a reason I dropped it?
I got the painting.
part looks like there's so many settings you guys see this
you can change your brush size with control oh wait oh wait
my ears just perked up a little sorry can you say i can say
again please again how do i how do i clean myself i
accidentally made a mess you just repainted with a different
color but i can't forget my color back like that'll be
that's fine that's fine i'm i'm good i did it how do i
change the size of this oh donkey i'm watching you wait whoa
do we like a little lanyard or is it
wow i thought it was gonna be like a little bomb or a
lanyard wait you have the same idea as me that is not no no
no no i didn't see the idea from you i stole this idea from
a dragon that's different
what's lime looking like oh my gosh i got front row seats
how did you make your paintbrush smaller it's control and
then you like move your mouse to make it smaller yeah where
oh the right click no right click and hold to change your
brush size if that's what you're talking about oh okay all
right let's see i don't think you can do fine details
That's loser's shock.
Yes, you can.
Look, I gave myself a belly button.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, you like that?
Like a belly button?
Yeah.
It was like one of those like 14 year old anime that was my
passion.
Wait, I can give myself toes.
You like paint on each other?
You cannot.
No, you can't.
I tried.
Oh, I can't give myself toes, unfortunately.
How do you stop painting?
Oh, just a bit of skin.
Oh, wait, we're all, let's all do pizza.
I like how Nimi actually made an effort to kind of like make
something that looks vaguely like her.
And then I'm like, no, I made an ass.
Wait, it's not me did too.
You look like Patrick.
Wait, which one are you?
Wait, how did I turn off everybody's names?
I didn't do the Patrick ass by accident.
You can tell which one I am because literally I just have an
ass and that's it.
It's kind of low down too.
My ass is on my thighs.
She's got like a little, it's just like a one cheek, but
she's got an ass.
Oh my God.
I just like unpainted it.
An accident.
I have it.
I think Matara's just.
naked i think i don't know what to draw she's on a nude
beach she went to the wrong face you have a good expression
thank you and then and then and then nimi and doki and me
were swimsuit i don't know what's going on i'm diving i'm
diving into the water let's see
hey oh how do you do that it's the it's the taunt which i
thought happened automatically but maybe that's something
people turn on to be fair because like people like every now
and again it taunts so that you have like some chance of
finding them again oh my god how do you erase i i just i
just color-picked my own body and painted over it again does
it look like i'm wearing a skirt or does it look like i
pooped myself um um you're like roguel
It does.
I feel like...
Oh my god.
Roadkill Matara.
Wait, wait.
I need to draw.
Look at your crack though.
Hey, no looking, no looking.
Yeah, no looking for free.
Here, I'm gonna make little like cool.
Oh yeah.
Very nice.
Thank you.
They're like laced, you know?
Yeah.
wow the hardest part is literally coloring the rest of the
body when you're hiding
beautiful oh god what wait what's shadow the hedgehog no
there's like there's like an option here that just says
shadow and i don't know what that does oh yeah you can make
yourself shiny too wait why don't you turn off your shadow
oh oh wait no that's cheating that's cheating we do not no
that's not cheating that's a giveaway yeah what the heck
technically you still have some lighting oh we're all so
beautiful guys we're at the yeah what do you mean what neem
what Apparently what it does is it's to help you color
matte.
It doesn't turn out for others.
I see, I see.
That's cool.
Wait, you guys are- How's Mimi like metallic though?
Yeah, wait, Snowy, you're just white now.
Oh.
What happened to you?
I'm trying to make myself beautifully shiny.
Like I've been getting my tan on.
Like a Pokemon.
Yeah, she's like the Terminator now.
Wait, where's the shiny- Okay, I think I accidentally made
myself look like a stripper.
what is that what is this is what I wanted to add like lines
and stuff and like the wrong place Natara what do you mean
on the wrong place wait I can't get up too high well it's
for the illusion you know it's for the nipple illusion maybe
they're just like being pressed up also that's not my nipple
that's my birthmark oh it's like your mole yeah it's like
where they shot you from your exact oh my god they they
killed me a lot of places yeah they want to make sure you
stay dead they wanted to make sure oops i'm gonna find all
the movies are just pressed up fruitinger arrow i'm still
i'm gonna figure out where the fuck you are coming from oh
my god snuffy you look so cool i'm like in line with just
the but windows seven you know the windows seven
Like, when you guys click it, it, like, deletes your entire
canvas.
What do you mean by that?
Oh, no, because, like, Mimi and Snuffy are redrawing their
thing.
No, I just wanted to become a town.
Oh, you just...
I didn't look at any Chinese.
What does roughness do?
Yeah, my chat keeps explaining it to me, but it hasn't
actually helped.
Oh, wait.
Never mind.
Now, I don't have a bald spot.
No longer bald.
ladies oh i'm now a totally different color okay oh god huh
oh you can see my butt a little bit if i crouch like this oh
is there like i want to see my like oh nice yeah you can do
a little do a little butt crack yeah you see a little bit of
a butt here yeah we're getting way into it in the menu
to each other everything yeah not to not to underwear shame
you but why is your underwear so low doki in the back it's
like super oh my gosh yeah girl what the heck when you're
walking if i got what i you know when i got what i got you
gotta grab show it you know yeah flex it down you have what
you have i got the little hair stop that's your little hair
i love it okay what is wait is that what's lime what's yours
so people people people who want to hunt stand here
apparently i i nominate lime lime as the hunter sure at
least wait snuffy what what are you snuffy she's already
getting she's already practicing she's she's making camo
right now oh my god wait when you run look look look up oh
my god that's amazing
the birds are beautiful this is a crazy pose that's awesome
i'm so excited you're gonna make me oh my god yeah you are
gonna force people to hunt it's like it will force people to
hunt if nobody volunteers yeah yeah I believe as a good
practice run yeah okay wait 200 you're not the only one no
no no it's gonna it's gonna choose one of us oh you're gonna
gamba yeah and maybe yeah I feel bad to put my wife in this
position you know wait which wife is this is this like a
wife number what's your wife tier list it does I love all my
women equally that's a lie that's what I feel like I just
the like tv drama like wow are you making a flag stuffy like
what i'm flipping burger
you should add the little like um what is it called the
little sesame seeds on yeah yeah yeah i got it i see what do
you think we'll never yeah we'll never know where stuffy is
delicious wait can you imagine we spawn in a cafeteria what
does it look like when you're prone almost like a burger i
think you might need to pose first yeah i see that oh no my
butt looks very unfortunate like this let me see all right
are you guys all ready guys we are yeah um wait oh configure
your map are there five of us one two three yeah okay so we
can't have even teams okay as always yeah usually there are
way fewer hunters than like uh hires all right i'm gonna oh
wait do we want infection basic or what's i guess basically
it's like just one that's not infection so you can see what
other people are hiding it's good too because it's not as
lonely for the hunter all right we could do we could do
basic first and then try infection later so i'm just gonna
be a little okay i'm a slow learner i need like a few times
to learn so don't don't make fun of me i think hunter is
more simple you just look around and shoot people if yeah
that's really yeah and then like from the eye like to play
hunter because you don't do any painting yeah yeah yeah oh
my god are you guys ready starting game i am 12 second
buffer time wait 12 seconds to find our place no no no no no
this is our place this is the lobby we hide It's me.
I'm bummed so.
All right, everyone.
We have 53 seconds.
Okay, I might have made it too short.
I might have made it too short, guys.
I don't even know.
Oh, no.
In fairness, I think a lot of the crazy ones that you see,
people actually like, they continue painting after it
starts.
They get like the basics in.
Okay, wait, how do I get paint?
Yeah, because otherwise the hunters would get so fucking
bored, like locked in here for like two minutes.
or something while you prep it's like no oh no we've already
starting yeah i'm huge is anybody else just like huge like
how do you become small i don't know i can't paint anymore
what's going on
I'm gonna give you an extra 20 seconds of grace because Nimi
didn't realize we were playing yet So I'm just gonna stand
here and wait I was just running around trying to find a
good spot Just waiting waiting for a moment.
Yeah, just wait 20 more minutes, please Waiting waiting keep
waiting.
I keep waiting.
I'm five four three two one.
I'm coming
oh my god she just walked past me you can't have the folks
just say things like that she just walked past me mind game
mind game mind game i think the moment you see me you're
gonna find me yeah that is what seeing people tend to do i
think she'll i thought it was gonna be so good
how do you go to the camera mode i'm scared to push any
buttons yeah how do you oh it's five switch to free camera
wait how did you find that out right we just pressing random
buttons i saw on the screen it said yeah you can scroll how
big is the area oh it's okay it's okay i don't know how to
like keep going on my scroll time there's no way there's no
way she'll know because she literally just passed me by
there's no way she knows i love it guys how do i see where
you guys are if i'm on your team press four or five actually
seem to go off that sucks you push the buttons do it there's
lots of rooms this house really freaking big i'm not gonna
lie yeah i'm in the library right now so she i don't think
she'll know where it is don't you just inventing there's a
library with the candlestick oh man wait i'm kind of
sticking near just in case because like i don't know if
anybody went really far
wait that's why the whistle is a thing just to make it fair
oh my god i've seen Wait, I want to see.
I want to see.
What is that?
Oh, you're getting hot.
You're getting hot.
Why is there a random food in here?
You're getting cold.
Vegetable.
You're getting hotter.
You're getting cold.
Oh, shit.
Oh, it's a sabotage.
The team's sabotage.
I was fucking around.
I said she was getting colder.
It's okay, Mimi.
You can sabotage her back.
No, I said you were getting cold.
Sabotage her back, Mimi.
No, I wasn't sabotage.
I swear you weren't so much I said I was making up shit I
didn't think you would think I was making it up as you were
like making incredibly accurate shit yes I think she's
actually 12 steps to the left like there is a library front
yeah there's actually a library I had like 10 seconds I just
hit the freaking corner i'm so this is like somewhat
difficult because it's it is it feels easy but then you're
also like darn darn okay well how did you guys get smaller
my character was so big you didn't do i just have to start i
wonder if it's randomized or something oh my god that's so
much stress i didn't get smaller i didn't get smaller highly
There's definitely music.
Where is Limo?
Anyway, I feel like I haven't seen her yet.
There's a very small amount of music playing.
Yeah.
It's very small.
I can just hear going, no.
I feel like I haven't seen her yet.
All right.
My wife.
I got you, my wife.
Have you seen her yet?
Oh, you're close to the top.
Yeah, we should turn the automatic.
She whistled at me.
It was kind of hot, man.
No, I pressed it.
I like it.
I want her to know what I was about.
I keep getting stuck on objects.
on objects i can't get up the stairs no i'm whistling come
back i cannot see you i cannot where could she be where
could matara be where could she be it's pretty creative I
would keep Matara on me.
Longer than I swanked in there.
Matara, you spit.
Okay, live.
She's right there.
Get her.
I would never.
I could have lived.
I would definitely get a better.
Oh, that's so funny.
That she felt you before me.
You literally were like, oh man, if I don't play very good,
don't bully me.
And that you were the only one alive.
You just humble flexed on us.
No, my favorite part is that I accidentally got Toki.
He got me killed.
Like, let's walk past me like several times.
You got Mimi though, so it's only fair.
I was in accident.
I was just like, oh, she's not there.
She's not there.
i think automatic taunting and maybe longer for the yeah
yeah i'll do that let's yeah that sounds good what is yeah
there's a horror it's really hard to find it it is you have
no idea like it's like was there someone in that room don't
know man there's no oh forced taunting how many seconds do
you guys want it maybe every 30 okay yeah 20 30.
i think it goes up to wait oh i know 20 might be too small
because you can just wait in the same room no all right 30
and then search time wait hunter wait time how many seconds
do we need to hide um definitely a little bit more time than
now but not much too much maybe because you could kind of
keep painting yourself a quiet 120 seconds only 120 seconds
and then actually 120 yeah yeah yeah all right we'll do
another basic ground all right uh sub zero mean we'll do a
new oh my god we can be in the back rooms back rooms all
right oh my gosh oh my god i like oh wait it resets her oh
it resets her body pain i didn't even know i know i know all
our work our masterpieces what the heck i know oh my god
this game's fun oh is it me i think it's got it exciting
exciting exciting oh i got oh there's the back rooms oh my
god i'm crazy so excited oh wait remember the plan girls you
whistle at me because i'm sexy i think it's automatic now
can i like oh damn wait wait i have an idea i know what i'm
gonna be you whistle at me because i'm sexy can i not go up
here apparently oh this might be too ambitious
ambitious nutritious oh move up nutritious oh move up past
dishes okay i think this is this is good
hunter applicants should stand here oh what the fuck i don't
want to strike on girls you have a minute left and i'll give
you an extra like 15 seconds oh no i won't actually why is
the painting laggy for anybody else it's like really bad no
yeah it was lagging for me a little bit.
I'm all right.
It takes a second to.
Oh, this is bad for me.
Never mind.
I'm no longer confident in my idea.
I.
Oh, why is it?
Why is it black?
You can't, you can't make yourself smaller, right?
Like, do you can't do that?
No, no.
It was, yeah, you just felt like you were smaller.
I will say, Doki, last game when you like did yourself as
one of the hanging clothes, i actually thought it was so
funny i thought it was such a good disguise i was like yeah
and then you whistled and then you whistled yeah but you
know what like it was kind of unfair we didn't have the
whistles on and i gotta i gotta cheat for my wife oh all
right ladies good
I don't know.
It's either it's either godly or just gonna instantly get me
killed.
Mine's pretty dumb.
I don't think I'm gonna live, guys.
I don't think so.
Hey, can I get a little?
Can I get a little?
Oh, I'm just scared.
I don't seem to really get this to stick.
It's weird.
I don't remember what color this was.
Wait, where did that come from?
Oh, I see you pick and then.
Ah, okay.
Wait, how do you guys look at your other stuff?
Like, how do you look at each other if you're...
Oh, push five, and then you can go through.
Oh, my God, this is tough.
It all looks the...
I wonder if it's going to be very obvious when I see
somebody.
Oh, my God.
Are you kidding me?
I think I'm going to be really obvious.
Oh, no.
Oh, my God, what did I...
Oh, shit.
Oh, somebody's close.
What is that?
I think I see what you mean now.
But it's always when you see somebody.
I just see a little hair.
Wait, you didn't even let me negotiate.
Oh, oh, it is.
The person got smart.
No, no, no.
That was so smart.
Happy, that was so good.
Because there's these two.
That was actually so good.
If I had seen any of the first two signs first, I don't know
if I would have recognized you.
like that was really good oh my god no live live is gonna
pledge this for us don't worry stuffy even if we're done
then live would help us win are you sure live that you
haven't played it yet like i'm sure i'm sure
it's hard to hear where the where the sounds are coming from
hold on let me put the sound up a volume up I have never
seen the bathrooms movie this just looks like a like a
museum either someone's just furniture out there I mean
that's what and I think I'm gonna have nightmares oh my gosh
is it just scary it's freaky it's more freaky than scary oh
well now I'm interested I'm gonna trouble with like here
it's coming from here somewhere I heard it.
I heard somebody.
Oh, everybody.
You know how you're close to somebody when everybody shuts
up?
No, I was just adjusting my volume.
I definitely heard something from here, I think.
I was adjusting my audio.
No, I was being quiet because I was scared.
Oh, you were so far away from them.
Well, I hear the whistle how close it is.
So far away.
I hear where the whistle is.
I hear the whistle.
whistle is oh you're getting warmer no you're getting colder
you're getting colder wait wait i know i know there must be
okay let me try to check here unless somebody switched
positions oh oh that'd be evil i keep messing up the
controls i i think you is there somebody here there's i
don't know this is oh i heard it i heard it is it automatic
at the moment i'm not doing it on purpose yeah it is yeah
it's every 30 seconds yeah yeah that's the other one oh man
it's kind of hard to hear the whistle like because i'm
congested i can't fully understand where it's coming from
yeah to be fair you thought neemie and snuffy sounded the
same i did i did you said i sound like an un-evolved version
of snuffy
how do i meant to like the pokemon terms you know Okay, let
me go back to what I know.
I'm old, it's okay.
Okay, I'm pretty pleased with it.
Hags to hag to hag communication.
That's literally...
Okay, I must go back to what I know.
I felt so confident finding two of you and now I'm like,
Yeah, but you've...
I forgive you on one of them and the other one you have no
excuse.
Oh.
Oh no.
I have to trust the other one is here too because the other
ping was coming from here.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Nine seconds.
You have eight, seven.
Only a few seconds.
Oh, Matara.
I don't know.
I can't hear you.
Yeah!
Good job.
Where were you?
You can see.
Oh, that's really good.
Yeah.
I was never going to find you.
See, I told you that I was going to clutch it for us.
Oh my God.
That was really good.
I saw some of these.
Mimis was so good though.
12 whole points we're gaming.
So we're smart Nimi.
I swear to God, I like, it's only because I passed here.
And then like I saw your head a little bit.
And I was like, wait a second.
I have a balloon.
Just a balloon.
Just a beautiful balloon.
Nobody here.
Don't worry about it.
shiny balloon all right now us three we can gotcha it do we
want to maybe put it up a little bit the whistle oh it's so
just a little bit higher yeah let's put it up because we
only have one speaker so yeah because i'll do 40 seconds
because they're small down oh yeah yeah pour down like
longer between them oh like it being 30 seconds made it like
it was very obvious for me where you girls were at a certain
point oh okay i'll make it 40 or make it 45 yeah even with
my bad ears i still was kind of like oh what you love okay
but i got a bunch of you get out of the circle you already
seeked same with you alamo hey i'll get out it's time to
express yourself creatively it's time for us to take oh it's
time for me to shoot somebody oh oh i i keep putting in the
back rooms again oh wait we got back rooms i forgot to
change the map That's okay.
That's okay.
I forgot about that.
It's kind of good to know the map a little bit.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
All right.
My gamer eyes are on.
While you guys are doing that, I'm going to still try and
figure out how to get rid of Matara in the corner.
Oh my god.
I didn't.
Come on.
We don't want to get rid of Matara.
I'm going to learn how to dispose of Matara.
Yeah, I'm going to try and learn how to get rid of this
cockroach real quick.
I do.
You're just there.
Like just I don't know why you're there.
I Because I love you and I'm moving in.
Wait, wait, okay.
Is it from VTube studio?
Is it from VTube studio and not OBS?
It's a foogie.
It's from my foogie.
She's just there Wait, what do I kick her out?
I want to move her to a different voice chat and then move
her back.
Don't kick me out.
Oh, she disappeared.
Okay, and now move her back.
Oh, yes, she came back and she I didn't actually move myself
back.
Somebody else moved me back.
No, I moved you back.
I was testing a theory out.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
I want to see how long I can get away with this actually.
You're hitting an undo button.
Wait, you're my alert?
Why are you my alert?
Is that why I haven't been having alerts anymore?
Is that?
What happened?
How'd you even accomplish that?
Making somebody your alerts?
Guys, I think it...
My alerts weren't working because I actually put her as my
Fugie.
I didn't even.
That's me.
I'm your Fugie.
I'm going to be able to change that again.
Oh my god.
I have no fix it.
I don't remember.
What's the alert?
Okay, guys.
I'll fix it later.
The button doesn't work.
All right.
I'm ready.
The picker.
The picker doesn't work.
All right.
I'm here.
This one I kind of fucked her out with.
i want to see how so how bad it is oh you around the wind
okay wait i want to see where are you guys you'll never find
me a color picker doesn't work
it was definitely just the color picker yeah definitely
their picker just didn't work guys that's not you got an
alert you got an alert you got an alert somebody just
donated bitties
big bitties big big bitties
also by the way you have unlimited ammo so technically i
could just i just start shooting i just Oh, look at her.
Oh, I'm meta-gaming right now.
Suddenly I just start blasting.
I wonder if there's like a good appropriate amount of ammo,
right?
So you're not just like spraying everything.
Oh, you guys are close to me.
You're like right in front of me, aren't you?
You're literally right in front of me.
somewhere i don't know maybe i'm a sushi any final words
whoever this person is in the corner of the vending machine
my final words is uh b7 oh no oh i'm so bad no you were
actually really good it was growling at me saying that i was
like i was too hidden and it was gonna highlight you i was
like i don't know i thought that was the point do i get
points for um taunting i don't know but do you know it's
it's it's literally just if they walk like oh you're on
their screen but they don't see you yeah oh so i walk close
to snuffy so time oh i haven't been there i haven't been
near matara's people like admits like an effect or something
is that what it is did i did i expose myself by painting no
no no i did not see any exposure i literally just walked
past and was like hey that that's somebody right there lime
hold my hand hold my hand lime if you see my hiding spot
it's so bad i love it how much can i do i can't believe you
lasted longer than me that's i mean she hasn't she hasn't
been near me me in fairness she took she looks at me i'm
dead somewhere where i haven't been to yet yeah oh my gosh
i've done everything looks the same this is the back room i
know right it all looks the same
little hot am i hot what am i mark you're hot then you're
cold you're yes then you're no marco you're in then you're
out you're up then you're like
and it's tight it's tight i got a bunch of points all right
dokey you're up and you're down you're cold oh my god where
is that whistle coming from i have to up the game volume the
girl kiss i don't know if you're finding her i'm gonna be
honest no don't say that she has like i mean you at one
point you were really close and you didn't Yeah, I just I
just did it.
And you think she's going to remember every every item that
she looked at.
Oh, okay.
What are you?
I can't hear you.
Mint.
It's the final.
I think you're going to love it.
I'm just trying to find Matai right now.
She's somewhere.
You'll never find me.
Bye.
All right.
Oh, dang it.
I was like zoning freak out.
I was like, what?
Oh, Mint.
And you'll never find is it 30 more seconds.
Oh my god, come on, come on.
Where is she?
You'll never find me.
Where's the whistle?
Can you blow my whistle, baby?
Whistle, baby.
Let me know.
Okay, give me one more whistle.
Come on, give me one more.
Oh.
I don't need one more whistle.
I got you all.
I don't need it.
How did you know?
Was it because of the close to me score or what?
No, no.
I literally was just like, I'm gonna crouch down.
Like I'm just a gamer.
I should have not hit on the ceiling when it's Doki.
Of course, Doki would look up, guys.
Yeah.
I wonder why I got less points than lime and snuffing.
Because I just stared at me before shooting me, so I got
like a ton of points right before I died.
I gave Snuffy a chat.
Final words.
I gave her a final words.
Did you want any final words?
Let's wait for Minto.
Oh, my gosh.
Let's make a little star.
fish pile yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah oh I'm
practicing my painting oh space button space button like I'm
80 years old the space button lets you color pick oh wait
what do you mean you guys haven't been color-picking oh no I
have been if I've been picking I'm using the eyedropper
symbol the eyedropper doesn't work oh okay that made a lot
more sense i was like the the eyedropper destroyed me
nothing to do with my hiding spot oh my god practicing
painting right now wait that's not how you draw an r okay
let me practice on oh my god no not the sideways why can't
you position there you go all right right here watch this
i'm gonna blend with the floor so good you see i'm gonna
practice i'm practicing i'm metagaming right now practicing
practicing gaming wait does v turn off your shadow for
everyone or just for i don't know i'm getting conflicting
answers from my chat so i see i mean it seems well i see it
turning off for you guys my shadow on my shadow's off right
now i see it off okay i turned it on i turned it on do you
guys see it i see it turns off for yourself then wait but i
don't see it now yeah i turn it off again okay and then i'm
turning it on do you see it now i see it yeah yeah yeah so
you just turn it off yourself okay guys think lynch's gonna
notice me all right wait how do you you can add texture how
do you how do you add texture someone was like you can add
texture but i think they're fucking with me you can paint it
yourself i was gonna say i feel like i have to paint it
myself yeah oh my god wait wait i'm getting so good at this
game wait oh i moved i no my positioning
i saw a clip of some of like a streamer playing against like
pro pro mecha chameleon players and they hit on a painting
like an actual like renaissance painting and it was we had
like a million players already i know it just pops up in my
algorithm yeah yeah she's been training yeah most practices
before we collab and then she thought i was some pro like a
chameleon players yeah i'm watching bots right now i'm
studying i'm writing notes learning the strats let me see if
i can find it It was crazy.
Wait, it was like a, I think it was like a Minecrafter, too,
playing with, like, like, crazy viewers.
Oh, my gosh.
Crazy viewers.
The viewers were crazy.
She thinks y'all crazy viewers.
I don't know what the roughness slider does.
No, it makes light, like, reflect on you differently, I
think.
You look more like matte, I guess.
And you don't, like, oh.
contain much reflection oh like when I was the shiny balloon
I was smooth well welcome back welcome back cheater welcome
back welcome back she wouldn't tell us what her what the
thing she was working on oh yeah we're all drawing we're all
drawing that's why oh I think it's her settings too she has
a new setup now she's in her closet yeah she's back in the
closet real ones no one's no where is the painting mid this
is where you unmute yourself and say hi to everybody i think
just like if you don't respond it starts becoming bullying
when we're like making fun of you yeah yeah yeah yeah damn
oh this is oh she's not responding she hates us big drama
oh my god you girls are actually practicing practicing let's
go i'm becoming one with the floor and the floor is with me
after i got everybody they're all like not again you just
said you were watching pros she's out here like training
she's out here like training i'm not even yeah yeah just
trying to find a clip right now i was trying to find it so
you're saying it's the algorithm's fault i have shirtless
men doing pottery on my tick tock yes yeah maybe yeah we can
hear you but you can't hear us oh you can't why can't i hear
you i can't hear you wait but we see yeah we hear you mint
if you can hear me say that Look at this, though.
Love me.
That's smart.
Oh, that is funny.
That is really good.
I'm still trying to find the painting strat.
I mean, that could be worse.
Oh, I need to do this side.
Oh, it's this one.
This one.
Look at this.
This one's crazy.
This is what I was seeing.
This is the one clip I saw.
Wait, what?
I accidentally changed my game to Spanish.
See?
wait that's not even possible they have to have mobs or
something there's no no yeah there's no way they actually
put themselves doesn't get that small also you like really
it's just a spanish buff it's a spanish buff oh this one why
does he sound like you look good lime this is the one i was
talking about chat i'm i'm learning i'm learning yeah that's
why the more we play the more the we can we can do this we
can find a painting and replicate this lime did you do like
roughness or anything on your brush for this for she's just
talented like that wait let me tell her this is art degree
to you guys I told you the password was secure you guys I
told you No, but I know no one knew.
Maybe you're right.
I knew I was right.
Does anybody else have an art degree before we go in?
Just so I know.
I mean, mine's game art.
It doesn't count on a real art degree.
Oh, my God.
I think, you know what?
No, wait, game art is literally what's going to help you
here yeah what the okay but if you look at the side i think
it might not be as good as you think it is the side isn't
the angle i'm doing it as if we're looking straight on hi
hello hello it's a straight on painting really creepy we're
all we're practicing right now no one's moving everyone's
just standing white people the white people girl wait i
don't think mint can still can't hear us mint she just came
in cold as white people and then just left we should just
make we should make mint be the seeker we have all the
practices yeah yeah oh no yeah we're pros now i think it's
probably easier to seek uh than it is to to hide but it's a
low in the existence yes she has she has to be alone but not
really because everyone's like hey hot stuff a little bit
stressful when everyone's like you didn't see me it's oh
it's the high school bullying again oh welcome back this is
why i sold seven million copies
have the game yeah apparently yeah apparently it sold seven
million copies what is i'm actually very pleased with mine
with mine you know what i know what i'm gonna do next game
you better watch out next game limo i don't know okay you
better watch out all right i think min is still fixing her
setup stuffy why are you just what are you like in fetish
well wait that's really good Are you in finished gear right
as the BDSM thing?
I'm testing out the metallic feature.
Wait, she's in the gift suit.
But it's okay.
It's legal on Twitch.
Whoa.
Well, it's just a bulletin ball.
It's okay.
You can show it on Twitch, guys.
Hey.
There's nothing here.
I'm just on metallic.
Louncing.
It's just her daily outfit.
My daily outfit?
Yeah, as long as I don't turn the camera anywhere, this is
pretty good.
As long as I close my eyes and pretend this is perfect.
I still think it's really good.
Thank you.
Me too.
Genuinely.
It is good.
Yeah, I think so too.
I'll leave for a minute.
I'm going to go to the bathroom really quick.
I think maybe I distorted that.
Damn right I am.
Why am I stuck in this place?
pose i can't move my pose oh there it is ha ha oh wait
that's a cool pose i'm doing yoga downward dog needs help
yeah i need help too and i'm not here bragging i actually
can't hear anything is your discord settings correct did you
try turning it on
you should adjust the audio on this she might not have
adjusted on desktop now my discord's right okay i can't hear
anybody did you adjust the audio check the audio output i
figured out the blurring the blurring on the what blending
like yeah like you can blend a little like i messed around
with the roughness slightly and it let me blend this little
bit on the like on my white leg
the audio desktop hey hey what was it was a button on my
interface i had to press usb oh oh yeah that's it uh mint
mint you're gonna you're gonna be the seeker what does that
mean you're gonna try and find us yeah you're gonna see how
good we've been doing how much hold on let me start my like
a like a hazing yeah she's really just joining like man you
gotta do the bit where we'll laugh Alright, let's do...
What should we do?
Oh, we should do Osaka.
Oh!
In celebration of Mint being here.
Mint.
We're going to Japan.
We're going to Japan, yeah.
We're going to Japan, guys.
Your visa got approved.
Yes!
Yippee!
Japan!
Yay!
Hi Mint!
I will leave, sorry.
Hello.
Yeah, we're going to Japan, lime.
Oh, no, stuffy.
We're going to Japan!
uh gucci so samadesta
are you guys using in-game audio or no no no no so we could
fuck with people well you're like yeah you'll be like oh
you're getting closer you're getting closer all right are
you guys all ready i'm starting game now all right mince the
hundred stuffy get off get off no no wait it what it's gonna
force one of us on it is on it oh wait yeah she's still
starting her stream oh oh oh oh it's all right i did it
right well we're she has to find us anyway she has to we get
to prepare how do i find you guys oh you gotta wait you
gotta wait we're painting we're painting right now you gotta
wait oh my god everybody i just this would be like the
ultimate
oh god you someone come and paint bricks with me yeah okay
okay how do i how do i get out of this mode help okay i
figured it out sounds okay oh i got an idea oh i forgot to
turn on my okay everything's all right everything is fine oh
man oh man oh man i had to i was recording stuff with my
with my air conditioning off and it was so high that i have
this shirt that i got moji that's just like if you sweat you
won't see it through the shirt only on one side and i sweat
through it oh how do i oh that's oh i see i don't think my
hiding spot is that good but i just it won't be i'll find
you it's not it's not good i know mine's not bad wait are we
starting it not yet no no no we have 43 seconds no that's
actually four seconds get ready i had an argument with the
controls so i haven't actually painted anything oh i'm in
decisive it's over the way i thought i was so smart but this
is a lot harder than i expected yeah i think i'm not the
only one struggling right now rotate the camera oh wait this
is a terrible how am i gonna learn how to do all this it's
okay your job is just to shoot you're so you're you're gonna
be fine you're can i paint me in time okay i have seven
seconds before you leave the thing yes yeah but then like
doesn't really matter more time to paint because i didn't
have an argument with the controls this would be so much fun
whoa whoa whoa going into space okay no no wait oh shoot i
clicked out of the game wait oh i'm in paint mode shoot uh
guys we have more time the paint keep painting guys keep
painting what is that shooting things it's a little ball
it's a little ball so this is my first time playing this
game how do you yeah you shoot who you think first one for
us dude like that like i actually couldn't tell i think i
just got really lucky I didn't actually see anybody there.
Oh, who's cat calling me?
Oh, it has a mandatory cat call.
Oh, yeah, we have an automatic.
Oh, I see somebody.
Oh, my God.
You're doing this.
I didn't even get to look at her.
She's too powerful.
She's the only one, and she's almost gotten hold of us.
It's because she was sweating.
She literally was sweating before.
I love yours.
I'm so sweaty.
Oh my gosh.
You're so sweaty.
Wait, do you come back as a new person?
No, no, no.
We're doing basic so it's just you against the world.
How big is this map?
You can see where we were after you.
That's as big as it is.
Oh, this is it.
Oh, so you're watching me walk around?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We're watching you walk around.
You're so far.
Oh, wait, hold on.
Let me double check that my headphones are off.
Okay, good.
Left them right.
Stop.
I'm sorry.
You guys are hyping me up.
Woohoo!
Wait, I'm lost now.
Oh no, we still have 180 seconds!
You're getting colder, you're getting hotter and colder.
You know, you passed me by like 20 times.
Yeah, you are.
Oh wait, menopause is heading in now.
You like those?
What is it?
Menopause.
Metapause.
Don't you know how to tell you this.
Like the Pokemon?
You are next.
Not yet.
Where are you?
Mental loss in Osaka right now.
I am.
I've never been.
I have nobody to help me.
Oh, you've never been to Osaka?
No, I've never been.
Wait, how many times have you been to Japan?
Don't ask.
Oh, wait.
I've been to Osaka one time.
I went to USJ.
Wait, what's, oh, universe.
Oh, yeah, as I say, it's in universal.
Yeah, you can climb walls.
Wait, I can.
Nobody told me this.
I didn't know that.
How do I need this?
How do I climb the wall?
Wait, I don't even know where Matara is.
Wait, how do I climb the wall?
How do I climb the walls?
What the heck?
Where are you?
Oh, you're like right next to me.
Who is the most disguised person ever?
There's still two of us, by the way, Mint.
of us and you have like two minutes to find us so you have
so much time yeah a lot of time it's it's it's like it's
interesting because you can have the best hiding place ever
but actually are no points because they don't like the
points are based on whether or not they're looking at you
but don't perceive oh i need to look oh wait oh my god but
sarah i think he's never gonna find you Yeah, we're going to
find you.
We're going to find you.
No, no, no.
I mean, space on the wall.
Is that how you climb?
There's not much space vertically.
But I mean, oh, shoot, I'm climbing.
Whoa.
I'm hearing whistle, baby.
I'm stuck.
Oh, it's stuck in your bed already.
Yeah, you're stuck in your bed.
I thought that you were living despite it all.
I know.
Oh, I don't know.
I'm stuck!
Wait, give me a hint.
It's in Japan.
I don't know why you're flying.
It was good.
But I mean there should always be.
We're somewhere in Japan.
That's somewhere in Japan.
Somewhere in Japan.
You know what they say about Galen?
I can hear the clock.
I'm in Osaka right now.
This is hard by myself.
Oh my god.
his mince never been yeah oh shoot i can't get on the top of
this pole
you would not make it i'm climbing i see you
no i'm sorry for you i pressed the wrong button that's not
what he was practicing the pig the pig Min, do you want to
see where I was?
Yeah, where were you?
You can tell me that.
You almost got me, but then you doubted yourself.
Oh, I see it.
Wait, where is it?
It's up top of the air conditioning.
She's there.
Oh, my God.
I didn't know how to climb.
It was in front of your face the entire time.
Oh, my God.
I did not have enough time to paint.
I'm stuck in the wall.
The fact that we can climb up is crazy.
I didn't know that.
Yeah.
Guys, the 200 frames, guys.
I'm playing on a potato PC.
It's like 228.
I got reflex on.
There's no way you're catching me.
I have my graphics are high right now.
I didn't even get to toad my graphics.
I'm using a special config to remove the shadows for those
extra frames.
Take my latency down by like 0.2 seconds.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, someone's talking in game.
Who is it?
Oh, I see me.
Oh, yeah, I need to turn it on.
I accidentally returned the title.
Hold on.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
There is a shadow button.
Oh, shadow is V in.
Oh, I see.
Yeah, when you're in paint mode.
Oh, man, the password shows if you show the game screen.
So don't show the password.
I know.
Hold on.
Wait, find server.
My chat's being mean to me, Doki.
And it's saying, like, nobody understands your nerd speak.
Doki understands my nerd speak.
Yeah, I understand.
Yeah, she does.
She plays the first person shooter.
Yeah, yeah.
I know about the NVIDIA reflex and the V-Sync on.
I don't know what V-Sync on does, but I know it exists.
Yeah, exactly.
You engage, you engage V-Sync, you cap your frame rate, and
then you turn on G-Sync.
Yeah, yeah.
G-Sync?
Those words.
I mean so.
It's not like G-Sync, so I can watch my dishes.
G-Sync.
Like a G-Sync.
Oh, wait, let me ban this guy very quickly.
Oh, me too.
Get him.
Someone else in here?
Oh, you can pose.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'll also get him.
I bet it's the same guy.
Send him to the fig.
Yeah.
Yeah, send him to the fig.
Send him to the fig.
Send him to the back rooms.
To the back rooms.
All right.
Who hasn't?
Oh, wait.
Who hasn't done seeking yet?
Snuffy, right?
Snuffy.
Snuffy's the last one.
I have.
Snuffy and Nimmy.
Oh, and Nimmy hasn't either.
Oh, it's like I have, so I don't have to do it.
It's actually really fun, Nimmy.
I don't know if you like it.
Yeah, it really is.
It's pretty fun.
I can't do it.
Oh, wow.
Look at me go.
I'm practicing right now.
I'm practicing for my dodges.
Oh, my gosh.
Just do what I do and don't care.
She's not interested in the painting.
She's just going to parkour where I'm at.
I'm just gonna start off just a T pose.
You'd probably win if it was me.
I'm team.
Wait, I'm gonna paint myself.
We're gonna do this.
This is hard.
Are you guys using tablets or your mouse?
No, you were using our mouse.
Yeah.
Okay, wait.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no tablets.
Honestly, the painting is so laggy that I think even if I
had a tablet, it wouldn't help.
Like I could go try hard with my tablet.
It's in the cupboard somewhere.
It feels like you don't get enough time.
just the time i could make it longer is you're supposed to i
feel like the point is you're supposed to keep drawing after
it starts yeah you can you can refine your painting or
something because i've been trying and i just it doesn't no
it doesn't the time a little longer i'll do it 150 seconds
oh god yeah because i'm a new i'm a new i had 20 more
seconds to the clock all right let's do i'll do also mint i
really love your thumbnail oh thank you oh my gosh i spent
so much time i can tell thank you i can tell where did you
get your inspiration from for that god yeah it came to you
yeah literally in a dream like i'm like what just happened
oh my god i thought for a second you were saying god like
god don't even ask me but no you you mean you know how do i
make it thinner how do i make my thing stop taking her
medication god speak i have an idea what to do oh i see
you're terrifying i know what to do oh i couldn't make it
thinner you look like a cursed doll oh oh wow yee-ha
hee-hae-hae-hae-hae-hae-oh it's all in one room this one
might be a little rough a little scary scary wait i have an
idea wait i thought nimi i thought you were gonna be hunting
snuffy right just me snuffed no it's just one person i'll do
it next time one person yeah oh wow okay well no pressure no
pressure it's funny to laugh admit now i'm feeling it you'll
do fine you'll do great you'll do great i'm gonna hide
within the pp of this thing i have no idea where to hide
what the heck wait oh here wait did i do wait how do i do
this oh here we go wait how does it work oh no yeah in the
meantime did it work myself oh no myself wait why does it
say it's blue wait i'm more confused okay i give up it
didn't take long yeah i was gonna say i was fast are you
talking to me yeah you were like okay i give up
Wait, is it starting?
It's not starting.
No, no, we have plenty of time.
We have plenty of time.
I'm still running around.
Oh, so much time.
I still have not like...
So much time.
It's really hard to actually like see the details when
you're painting.
What the fuck is that?
I know.
It's not...
No, I'm not trying to...
Okay, I don't think I have a great hiding spot, but...
Neither.
I haven't even found a spot yet.
I'm yellowing this.
Just press space.
I haven't found a spot yet.
You have 40 seconds to pay.
i'll find one okay oh shoot i do not think i'm well hidden
but you know what yellow i'm hidden in plain sight i'm so
well i've got socks if anything i have my fps to come in
clutch you really do i feel like i feel like specifically
this is really dark and the game is like no no not that dark
maybe you need to do like manual adjustments maybe that's
how i feel right right yeah oh boy i think i'm good i think
you're great maybe not i think your hiding spot is very nice
mint you think so you see it yeah you if you press five and
then press four you're able to like look around yeah the
color no chat no that's not what i am please wait i'm
pressing numbers and it's not showing me anything but okay
guys oh my god this is so cute are you rennabon i thank you
are how fun i love random mine thank you guys i needed
something that made me feel like i think i i chose the wrong
spot it's okay my spot is hard and then i was like oh god i
have to commit i don't have time okay yeah i want to see
where how do you see find each other i think you're just
like you get out you push five and then you you go through
with your mouse This is really scary when you don't, when
you can't see anything like this.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, my game just crashed.
Oh, no!
What was her spot?
No, no, no, don't stay.
Just in case she's still in the game.
What?
How can I keep getting memory issues?
I love seeing some people still draw.
I'm trying to see if I can fix it.
Okay, wait.
That's actually kind of good now.
Okay.
I think I fixed it.
I think.
Wait, I can't see Doki.
Hold on.
I think I fixed it.
Doki.
Oh.
Wow.
I got one.
I didn't think it was possible.
You did.
I'm proud of you.
It was a good start.
Oh, she did get you.
I'm sorry, Lyme.
Sometimes it's like, you have such an obvious place, but if
the hunter doesn't look there, you're just lucky, you know?
Nui, I love your spot.
I'm not sure I was like I feel like a rage comic like
clenching my fist where like everyone just giggling I'm just
like that's actually pretty good now Doki yeah yeah I think
I think I fixed it guys I think I fixed it there's some
issues from certain angles she won't look at the angle
What was that?
Were you trying to ride the horse or were you part of it?
Yeah, outside of the statues.
Okay, from some angles it was really good, okay?
That was so cute.
I was like, is that somebody on the horse or like in the
statue too?
Oh my god.
Don't dodge it.
Where was your epic dodging?
yeah i got put against the cow it was i saw her did a double
take i was like it's over i was like that's a really lumpy
looking were those cows knocked over before did your girls
just talk them over false those cows cows cows the cows i
think they were knocked over cows yeah i was i was too i
should have committed i didn't know you actually saw me not
i just saw you i know i i probably would have gotten you but
i was just looking you're like you got too eager your hiding
spot is working by the way so don't say anything oh my god i
can't see what you guys are dressed up as i just see
dokeybird standing as a white person but can't you get a
free movement like the four or five everybody's just white
alive like technically i think and everybody a sample
nameplate.
Because I can't actually camera take off.
I think it's just Batara.
Oh my god!
Yay!
You guys played me the first time.
Batara, your little butt was so shaded, it threw the whole
thing off.
Oh, it's your shadows on.
You accidentally put shadows on.
Yeah, the shadows.
Wait, is that bad or good?
Bad, that's bad because your butt keeps shading in there.
ah my eyes saw a like the rump hyper fixated onto it my
ginormous fat don't be betrayed betrayed by the cake yeah
betrayed by the cake all right big baddie oh my gosh i
should have committed i should commit to my oh boy can't
wait oh boy all right i'll let you pick the map do you want
penguin hotels sugar ladders sewer
i'm starting now yuppie
yay yay i'm gonna run out of the circle at the last minute
just kind of a or is it kind of like a big gerbil let's go
all right we we go oh i love this new eyes whoa oh it's huge
more vending machines in the sewers why for food the rats
are hungry oh there's all the sewers in the way i have an
idea i have an idea too i don't have any idea i feel
overstimulated here i go i'm going this is a little this is
a little chaotic oh my god i can't get past this my idea
doesn't work because it won't let me climb yeah is it better
to do i'm gonna get context clues by what you're saying
right now and i'm gonna find out your hiding spot no you're
not no you're not you're gonna ask the carrots the cards
yeah i've already figured it out no i'm still trying to get
to my hiding spot five of cups i know you're near a cup oh
you also know i'm an alcoholic no you don't we all do that
we all do that it's like was that a secret okay i'm gonna
test real gamers okay so how do i turn off the um shadow
when you're in the painting mode uh you just press v
Is there an undo button or no?
No, you just paint over it.
Not that I can see, no.
Oh, shoot.
Yeah.
This is fine.
This is fine, everybody.
Good.
Guys, this is fine.
I believe in you.
This is, I'm also fine right now.
So fine.
So very fine.
Oh, shoot.
So you press V and then how do you know you're not shadowed?
Do you have to like do something?
Oh, you press V and that's, oh, it's, it's her voice.
How do I?
No, that's the one you're in the painting though.
Yeah.
Okay.
Make it small.
Like you.
Oh my god.
The seven seconds count, the countdown.
It's giving me so much anxiety right now.
I'm anxious.
Give me more time, please.
Give me more time.
Okay.
I'm still painting myself.
We're sitting in the exam hall freaking out.
We just need a little bit more time.
Just a little bit more time.
Yeah.
Give me more time.
Coach, coach, coach.
And just the I'm just.
trying to get my vision in oh god guys i'm so obvious i just
i don't know i freaked out oh my good your thing is pushed
uh your open mic matara you gotta press b you gotta press b
i know where you are oh okay yeah do i know where you are
now you're still uh oh can i go are you ready ready or not
oh yeah as soon as you're dropped in you can go I was gonna
be nice Proctor oh that's sweet of you oh nice oh I'll break
this off a little bit am I still on like open mic by the way
no you're fine I can't actually hear the open mic even when
it goes so I don't know if you press B it Mutes open mic, so
like hard.
I was like, suddenly do it.
What the heck?
Everybody has such good...
Lymo!
Honestly, Lymo's spot.
No, Mint.
I freaked out.
I didn't know where to put my spot.
Whoa, Doki, yours is pretty good too.
You guys have experience.
Mint, can you tell me my spot is good?
Can you tell me my spot is good?
I'm looking for you.
You look like a little poop.
Don't say that kind of stuff.
Oh.
I hear...
Wait, how do I get into free mode then?
I keep pressing 5 and it's not working.
You have to press 4, right?
Wait, but it says switch to free cam and it's 5.
Switch?
Oh, 5, then 4.
That makes no sense.
Now I know how you feel when I mispronounce words.
Oh my god, Mimi, you're such a handsome little guy.
Literally won't let me know.
Oh, I see it, though.
There it is.
Oh my god, she still has so long.
Oh my god, they're updating.
That means they're near.
No, we're not.
Oh, I like your outfit, Mimi.
Thank you.
I wish I could see it.
I can see it.
I think I need to know.
Oh, Mint, earlier today, I told Mimi, it's nice to e-meet
her, and she giggled.
Oh, I sure did.
I'll giggle again.
blushing now she's blushing what does that mean nice to like
me meet you it's like how you write emails to people you're
like wow nice to eat meet you like online wow i know that's
a good i think i'm i'm really proud of myself right now i'm
why why giggling oh shit it's hitman i just where did hitman
go wait i lost okay i found you oh no joki you have opened
my eyes in a way i didn't Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All those clips on my algorithm paid off.
Yeah.
Yeah, like yours is crazy.
It's me, I'm whistling.
I'm whistling.
Woo, woo, woo.
Woo, woo.
You about beyond the wall.
Wow, that's hard.
Woo-hoo.
You're getting hotter.
Actually, Doki like scoot over like a little bit.
I know.
not here just like scoot over like one bit i promise you
it'll really help no i know i'm really serious if i scoot
i'm gonna fall if i what do you mean you'll fall i'm gonna
fall she's not even here come on come on not even here come
on just do it she's literally next to me come on she's
literally next to me she's literally next to me yes she is
don't get i literally see her she is points for taunting no
she's actually so far she is so close she's looking at me do
you not okay i'm talking her away i'm taunting her she's
like her eyes do it don't you have no balls her eyes
actually do it with my eyes don't get somebody to count her
come on no no like humiliation this level is so hard
everybody has such good spots yeah this this level is pain i
know i can't believe that i was found so easily thank you i
wanted her to have a win so i jumped in the air thank you
it's my only win honestly everybody's just really hard in
this one i don't i don't think anybody could do this by
themselves yeah this one is like loaded I don't think if
even if we had infection on it would would mint mint be much
of a help would come on dookie you could have had it be like
really good looking oh my god look up neemie come here look
up wait come over yeah look up can i go to free cam neemie
look up i'm literally right below you just look up just look
up do you see it Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
this is why you should have moved over here in the wall.
That's crazy.
I was behind a little box at the little restaurant.
Limeos is also crazy.
What was lime?
Where was lime even?
Lime was like blended with the wall like, like PETA in the
Hunger Games.
It was crazy.
What would infection do?
Infections.
means that if you get shot, you help to hunt.
I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's basically that.
You want to turn on infection?
Wouldn't that be a cheat because then you see where
everybody else is?
You don't get to see where everybody is.
Yeah, you don't see.
Oh.
I will say that Mimi didn't see you guys, but I can glaze
myself a bit.
She literally like started walking on time.
Yeah, she has to watch that.
I don't know why I even saw you in the end.
I was like in this room.
I was like on top of the tanker.
you like you were just like looking for so long i'm proud
i'm proud of myself i didn't look at that from first game to
this game the character development all right we're doing
penguin hotel and then oh oh it's nothing you want to hunt
all right yeah all right penguin i did infection so if you
catch some wonder hunters oh okay okay people to my cause oh
i sure hope you don't terrible if i had to come and hunt
with you oh i just hate this penguin room nap is crazy hmm i
know who to be i'm trying to oh i know what to do so we
don't get to see anybody else yeah yeah this should be
pretty good oh we can't oh that's so sad yeah that's the
only problem with infection because otherwise you could like
when you die you just go to a little hiding spots you
already saw okay wait wait wait wait i have no idea No way I
figure it out.
I figure it out.
I have no idea where I'm going.
I'm scared.
I feel lonely.
There you go.
No one will find me.
No one will find me either.
I kind of want to be found.
You know what?
Snuffy.
If you don't find me, that's on you.
that's okay oh god okay time to paint okay me too i'm gonna
be in the most round oh yeah the most returned oh that's a
hit right there that's a hit it is that is a hint aren't we
like be around are we penguins or are we dancers are we
human dancing queen oh my wait it's not letting me like body
thingy.
Uh-oh.
It's not letting you like...
Get my booty hole.
Wait, I can do this.
It's not letting you pick what?
Like how I want to... Your nose?
No, my I heard it's not letting me pick my booty hole, so I
have no idea what you're doing.
Sorry, that was me talking about my booty hole.
Like it's not letting me pick how I want to be my body to
be.
Ooh.
for some reason it's like giving me problem with it that's
weird i'm scared okay i found it i had so much faith in my
abilities oh shoot i gotta keep going oh my okay oh okay
it's fine nothing happened okay i believe you you guys are
making concerning noises no everything's fine it's a very
serious map oh yeah uh okay i gotta catch them all guys oh
guys this is not looking good for me me either i smell girls
smell oh no do you not smell girls these penguins these are
not penguins right oh wait no these are penguins wait why
are they robots and penguins is this like a mario reference
big pen 15 ink i'm trying to zoom out and it won't let me
i'm trying to game is a little buggy i think is free cam am
i actually in free cam yeah there we go oh wow whoa sounds
like there might be a few are you ash catch them amongst
what are you oh is that what you're doing every time like
you hunt you just like there and paint yourself while you're
waiting for us that's cute digimon and then pokemon is a
little controversial no whoa someone can like i might have
picked one first over the other this is hard if you guys are
in this room say i oh oh i guess there's only one person in
that room oh it's i is the whole place a room or the one
he's just you just that would be
She's gonna catch him all.
Catch him, get him, get him, get him, get him.
Gotta catch him, get him, get him.
Gotta catch him, get him.
This is hard.
This is so much harder than the last time.
Snuffy, I swear you'll be able to find me.
There's, don't, you're gonna, what happens if I don't, huh?
Then everybody's gonna tell me that I'm a failure.
What?
I accidentally moved.
Oh, my God.
I definitely moved.
I might know where someone is.
I might find me I might know you guys you're all like oh
this is gonna be so easy no man you're you might have been
on top of me at one point you know I'm gonna catch them all.
Wait, no, let me catch one.
She is one.
Can somebody actually catch you?
She needs a hand.
She needs a hand up, guys.
Oh!
She got lads first.
Oh, nice.
I've got lads on my team.
Yeah, that, oh my gosh.
If I didn't second guys, that would have been like, she's so
good painting the wallpaper.
This makes me think like, um, that our hiding spots are
actually pretty good.
It's just when you know where people are.
you're like oh obviously you're here you know yeah when
you're actually searching for it you're like wait a second
this is rough have some guys please be gentle with me i
accidentally moved
is your pattern like gonna be horribly off center and like i
don't know i really don't know oh my god there's two of them
they're multiplying they're multiplying
has stayed alive i know hello everybody in this room i'm now
in this room if you're in this wedding wasn't bullying
nervous start oh wait you might have someone might have just
passed matara she just got 14 points somewhere okay what the
hell is wrong with you oh my god
it's very suspicious about all of these no one is safe i
mean technically you could just spam your bullets right wait
i can we see each other though like no no like every camp no
because then if you go on the other team it's gonna you're
gonna know yeah yeah oh that's fair oh one shot one this is
hard oh i don't even know where you girls are hold on let me
try no i don't know where anyone is are you i don't think
you can see when even no no no no free cam right yeah i no
longer want to be the hunter you guys no i'll be the hunter
next time where are you guys where are we oh this map is
rough gingerbread bodies how am i how are you not how is
this even possible this map is rough i kind of want us to do
it again with infection yeah we'll add more longer seeking
time longer seeking because i feel like the only like three
or four whistles actually go off before it ends yeah yeah i
have to say my chat was doubting my spot that was mine it
did not believe snuffy turn around
yeah baby come back to where you yeah where you were what
the hell was your spot wait very good Yes!
I did it!
Wait, where was Mimi?
Too powerful.
Where's Mimi?
Mimi is in this room.
Oh, that's so good!
Wait, what?
Nimi is so powerful!
Nimi was really good.
That one was hard.
I'm gonna cry.
I'm surprised.
Like, if I don't, like, if I don't find her, then
everybody's gonna laugh at me and I'm never gonna live it
down.
So that's now I'm going to be on my gravestone.
Thank you guys.
Thank you for the pressure.
I'm going to just associate every time.
It's like you forget, you think you forget about it.
And then like 20 years later, you're going to remember it
and you have like little memory.
It's going to come back in 20 years.
People will now know that if it was up to me, I couldn't, I
won't be able to ever find anything.
I will never be able to locate something.
Nobody will ever come to me.
Okay, Stephanie, do you know where your keys are?
Wait, no, you're that girl who couldn't find Minto in that
one thing.
Oh, sorry.
I was just, even, I even drew my butt hole.
like I think I'm so surprised he was able to draw all of
that within this within the second she was given that was
great did you draw while they were hot while they were
seeking me me me me yeah me me me I did I was drawing the
whole time yeah there was no way you could have finished
that in like the time we had I was still working on it up
until the end yeah yeah that's kind of like what I do I just
like sit there and paint the whole time yeah I'll add search
I'll add 20 more seconds to search time or you want maybe
short time between whistles too okay I'll put 35 seconds put
it down it's because when when the rooms are small the
whistles going off as often as they did felt like such a
cheap but when the rooms are big you kind of need the
whistles to go off I put 25 more seconds and search time all
right and then Download extra maps after that because we
could try the Minecraft map.
I want to do the Minecraft map.
Yeah.
The Minecraft map looks really fun.
Please.
I want to do Minecraft.
Oh, that was...
Fortnite un quarter?
Un quarter.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I fucked up.
Wait time, guys.
I fucked.
I accidentally reset.
Oh, it's 50 seconds.
Oh, fuck it.
That's okay.
Rush game.
Fast game!
Rush B!
I'll give you more time once I star if you need it.
Oh, that's sweet.
Thank you.
Yeah, I messed up there.
Wait, I'm gonna be Miffy.
Yeah.
I'm doing a good round.
Fun round.
Very good.
Wait, I... Let's see.
Oh, this is gonna be hard.
Wait, what if...
Oh, no.
I'm thinking right now.
You better be.
I'm still thinking right now.
The outward thought process.
Wait, we're doing infection, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh!
I picked a boring spot this time.
Oops.
I picked a really stupid spot.
Oh, I messed up my face, so please don't look at it.
Wait, okay.
Actually, the game is only letting me walk backwards.
Oh, I'm in paint mode.
I'm good someone's gonna be in these stripes I know it
whistle if you're in the stripes oh I messed up did you like
it I did like it I almost didn't see it I I didn't see it.
Oh.
Wait, but it's only like 50 seconds.
Oh, like, never mind.
Never mind.
Guys, I don't think I'm hiding as well as I could be.
Wait, why is this blinking?
Wait.
Why was it blinking?
Where'd you go?
I see it.
If they're blinking, that means they're cheating.
No, I'm not.
That means you're not.
Yeah, get her.
Get her.
you freaking cheater i didn't realize i was too much better
matara's always hiding under something who's left like that
oh yeah she is a cockroach it makes you feel good she
doesn't try to hide in plain sight she has to sneak area in
i like um when i'm sleeping to put my blanket all over my
face oh i can't believe it's a level for me didn't hide well
i promise like i have a big problem with my hiding spot oh
someone's near me please be gentle someone's near here be
good to be saying that i think you're just saying that oh i
heard the i'm on your team man i'm no i'm talking about
mataro oh my god okay okay when you do find me can you show
the others where i'm at just because i'm curious you just
want us to give I mean, I'll come find you, but then I'm
going to look away so that you don't get points.
Sure.
I mean, I'm not playing for points.
I'm playing for embarrassment.
Oh, she's like near me, near me.
That's me.
That's literally me letting you guys know that I'm there.
She's like next to me somewhere.
Like emotionally for us.
It sounded close to me too, though.
The freaking whistling is so hard.
The whistle's kind of shit.
Oh, I just reflected you.
I'm reflecting.
I was like, of course you're not going to shot your ass.
Wait, wait, wait, she's not human.
Wait, who are you?
Wait, but Tara, show us.
Show us.
She was a tree up here, like where I'm looking.
I was a Christmas tree, but I couldn't get down.
Oh my gosh.
So I was floating in the air.
She was a Christmas tree here.
She's somewhere next to me.
And I jump-scared myself with the humanoid and just shot
you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Remember when I let you win at the beginning?
Wait, no.
Wait, so who's left?
You let me win?
Didn't I refuse to shoot you at the very beginning?
you?
That's how that went.
For you to find everybody.
So quiet.
Nimi.
All right.
It's time to find Nimi.
Nimi.
Are you a little chocolate?
Are you?
I'm a little sweet treat.
You are a little sweet treat.
Where is Nimi?
Nimi.
Psst.
Nimi, give us a little whistle.
by the way the class oh no i haven't wait can you get up
there i looked at them but i don't know if i can get all the
way up all right can you get up there no no need me neemie
neemie neemie where was she she was right here right here on
me i knew she was on oh that is good look at this
everything oh wow that is good that is good he does really
well wow yeah you get a little thumbs up yeah i gave you a
thumbs up oh my gosh i only found it because i looked here
and i was like that looks like a that does not look right
dude for 50 second hiding plus an infection that was pretty
pretty good yeah yeah this boring spot though don't forget
to adjust the painting to time this time around i knew
somebody was a little stripe i knew oh yeah you want to try
that that's that's my own do we want to try the hotel again
with uh let's see whatever you guys want yeah with more time
for hotel um oh was that the penguin yeah the penguin hotel
yeah yeah all right penguin hotel 120 and wait time search
time 325 and then 35 seconds i don't mind trying to be Go
for it.
Go for it.
I have no respect for myself.
I don't want that to be the hunter either.
Please, please don't hide too well.
I beg you, please.
Don't worry.
There's, it's infection.
So you'll have, if you find one person.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I find one.
It'll let you.
Not even Lymo could find me too.
Whoa.
Well, now we know what your spot is though.
I have to redeem myself in this one.
That's my answer.
the next time we hang out i will redeem myself i have an
idea oh my gosh wait can i get through this i start
stuttering ask you what i'm talking about oh my god and then
we'll better be no baby better be oh no my lee okay i have i
have a plan
Oh shoot no, it's blinking.
Wait, why is it blinking all of a sudden?
Oh, because you're submerged.
You're cheating.
I'm not trying to.
That's what they all say.
Yee.
Let me do this.
Ladies, no pressure, but I'm coming.
Oh, wait, already?
Yeah.
Can you stop?
No, no, no, no.
I'm coming right now.
No, no, no.
Please stop.
I'm already looking for you.
I don't think so.
I'm already here.
I'm looking at you.
No, I don't believe you.
I promise you.
I'm going to make this work too.
I'm going to make this work.
You guys made this look so easy.
I don't think I'm pulling it off.
You got this.
I'm going to make it work.
Oh,
I'm so ready.
It's got to work, guys.
It's got to work.
ready or not here i come i'm not i'm not i'm already got a
plan i'm already oh oh oh gosh i'm lagging oh gosh all right
girls i've been searching for a while but now i'm finally
here yeah yeah oh my god there's rooms i've never even seen
before yeah maybe mine was a bad idea maybe why are you
laughing i just you know how like when you swap perspective
and you're you think it's so good and then you change his
perspective what's written on my back like click your canvas
i know what's written why did you write my name on your back
you freak honestly i was like oh that's gonna be kind of
like a move if i find her but i didn't even know it I
literally was just like what's written on my bag, but then I
remember that you are very likely to do that I was if I was
trying to make it work But it would tell me every time I
scooted in the toilet that I was too hidden.
Oh, were you shit?
Were you pooled?
That is good.
Yeah, I was trying to be a little Wait, why did Vittar go
straight to the toilet too?
Oh, you found her too.
Hey, honestly, I don't even know genuinely i don't know if
there's anyone else in here i'm just going through rooms i
didn't see before and but to be honest she like stood out in
the toilet like she was not hidden wait how do i get up oh
that's me oh i'm sorry mental being a little i was being a
little in the toilet yeah sorry i'm also not really looking
around wait how do i go like hard i feel like there's like
all the balloons are such a weird shape and the place is
really big yeah it's not that really shouldn't work all like
at all oh am i stuck in the stairs you guys oh are you no
you're so fine you're so good you're good yeah okay but it
wouldn't let me move yeah going back to my hiding spot from
before oh my god your steps are actually like oh they're
making me think maybe it's somebody else's Hmm.
Okay, okay.
I'm stuck.
I know previously Doki had a really good hiding spot with a
balloon.
Ah!
Yes!
My slime would look up.
She would be stealing over here by the exit.
Oh, of course.
She would look up.
That leaves Nimi and Snuffy.
Yeah, Doki, you always hide up.
Yeah.
doors don't look up the live of course would look up
oh oh someone's in here someone's in here yeah someone's in
where it's hard to talk because they could be upstairs and
it would still like sound like that no I don't know snuffy
I'm gonna see if anybody using using my hiding spot from
before Are you?
Are you?
I'm comfy, yeah.
Oh, is that a hint right there?
Kind of.
Oh, she might be near a couch.
Do you think I would find a couch comfortable?
Oh, see, I hear it in here, right?
Are you hearing it too, Lymo?
I don't know.
I can never actually tell where the whistles are coming
from.
Yeah, it's like in this room or the room next door to us.
I feel like...
Because they will play it once, my brain just goes, what the
fuck?
someone know me too because uh her her score went up so
where do you see her score yeah i'm metagaming right now
where do you see her score it's on the left side this
justifies this justifies my hunter game so good thank you
everybody oh my god wait are you kidding me i had no idea
you could see the scores this whole time oh she's near us
somewhere oh my god mimi's getting so good at this game
She's drawing textures now.
She's still drawing.
Are you still drawing?
Actually, I'm not this time.
Not this time.
I'm not as creative this time.
I feel like it's around here.
It's not a creative one.
You're always creative.
Tell me where you are.
That is shocking.
That is silly.
Okay, anyway.
Yeah, everybody.
She's an artist.
Artiste.
Where is she?
Good.
I'm just saying.
Yeah, I'm curious where Snuffy is.
This is Snuffy's revenge.
Snuffy, give us a hint.
Give us a hint.
Absolutely no, I hope you all perish.
I hope my spot is so easy.
You know, my spot is just so easy.
If you guys don't find me, it's super simple.
Damn.
She's gloating, guys.
I'm sorry, you're blind.
Toxic mecha chameleon player.
I have no idea.
I'm so excited to see where you girls were.
Good job.
She's definitely in this room.
Where are you?
Oh my god.
Debris never looked up.
Debris, I don't know.
You shut up.
So many times.
Where's Neemie?
Okay guys.
Oh my god.
I'm in my room.
I never even saw this room.
I had no idea.
I knew the room.
I knew you were in here!
I knew it!
Goddamn gamers never look up!
But thanks!
Oh, Limeo looks up for that, but not for...
I didn't even see her, though.
Oh my god.
Let me go...
Let me download the Minecraft map, guys.
Give me a sec.
Yippee!
I was trying to see.
Where did you end up hiding?
I was inside the armpit of one of the penguins.
do not infection so that we can see where each other are
yeah yeah yeah i agree even though it's fun to have teamwork
i like seeing everybody's silly ideas yeah i mean if
minecraft is too big then it's you know understandable but
all right let me see if i can find how to do this for the
power of friendship come oh where is it it is in workshop we
could always do two hunters now that we have ultra six of
us.
Oh, there's so many Minecraft maps.
Oh my god, there's Team Fortune.
Oh my god, there's Digital Circus.
I am disguising myself as Jack, so I just can't see Jack.
Maybe do no infection and two hunters or something.
Yeah, we can do that.
I'm gonna I'm subscribing real quick to Minecraft.
I subscribed to several Minecraft ones.
There's a Minecraft lobby.
You found her.
Hold on.
I think my computer is crashing.
Oh I need a second.
Okay.
I'm gonna grab the Simpsons one.
Oh, please, please.
Is there a Garfield one?
There is no Garfield one, unfortunately.
Where would you even be in like the comic?
I'm hiding in the lasagna.
It's all lasagna.
Oh, there's Peach's Castle.
I'm subscribing to Peach's Castle.
Oh, that's a good one.
Oh, there's SpongeBob.
There's Bikini Bottom.
All right, I subscribe to Bikini Bottom.
What else is there?
There's Luigi's Mansion.
I'll grab that.
Luigi's Mansion sounds really fun, actually.
Let's see.
Oh, there's CS.
There's Counter-Strike.
There's McDonald's.
There's the Peak Airport.
Wait, my chat brings up a good question.
If it's like in the settings i'm not sure if it is but can
we can we increase like the end game time so we can have
more of a chance yeah everybody's oh yeah we can do that
i'll increase that let's see where is the where are you also
jacks we're all jacks amazing yes i'm here downloading max
and you're jacks i don't even i couldn't remember what he
looked like i don't remember I think that's Josh.
Wait, there's a curse to cowardly die.
I look like Spyro.
Wait, there's FNAF.
Wait, I'll download the FNAF one.
Wait, do we also have to download the map?
Oh, we don't have to download the map.
You know when you join like a like a Gary's mod server or
like TTT or something?
Yeah.
No.
I don't know, Mom.
I'm checking anything.
Maybe.
Oh, there's the lush caves, too.
I'll grab that.
Pick something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm just downloading lots of maps right now for us.
There's Genshin Impact.
I don't...
Genshin Impact.
Send me to Minecraft right now.
Um, can you be a little bit patient?
I'm in, uh, Matara's peeing right now, so we have plenty of
time.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah.
No, I'm Jax from the Amazing Digital Circus.
will listen to me right now hi we're doing some like we're
doing some uh you know modern art we're expressing ourselves
i thought we were hugging episode nine we can do that too
it's it's like we're hugging if you're like you're you know
not as into the friendship as i am
this is the kind of yeah there we go looks cute oh that does
look cute falling down down all right i got oh my god
there's an overwatch there's leishon tower what oh wait
overwatch do oh there's a leishon tower okay wait where's
jacks i want to go to leishon tower wait wait is there
hanamura can we bring back hanamura okay but because all of
you guys are jacks we might as well do digital skins first
hold on
women yeah uh answer check time i'll do 60 seconds for
answer check time are we all back i'm so excited yeah all
right we're doing digital circus first i don't know what it
looks like it didn't have a preview image so we're gonna see
what it looks like can you guys give me a tldr oh i did
digital circus oh but like the spoiler they're in a digital
circus also i actually did infection so subscribe to it like
yeah yeah yeah okay I'm gonna leave you for dead oh God wait
does that say I need to download it still yes yeah yeah I
actually I forgot to do the two hunters thing so we're a one
hunter infection for this oh man it's at 98 spots nice ha ha
no spots I don't want to be the ceiling come down weird
right now why is this the ceiling come down for you guys or
is it just yeah it did we're still over like me me's still
up there i have no idea what this looks like oh my god we're
in the digital this is huge wait no i'm still in the ground
oh wait no wait it's too big here no no no wait wait what
are we oh gosh why is it glitching like crazy you guys Oh,
we still, we still only have one hunter.
Yeah, yeah, I forgot to, I forgot to do the settings.
Oh, okay, okay.
Wait, do we get to go to the, I'm stuck.
Nyrkis?
Yeah, this is like, jump off.
Are you guys, are you guys stuck?
Am I the only person that got out?
I got out.
I got out, I'm hiding.
It's so big, it's gonna take me 80 seconds to run to the
other side.
I know, this map is really big.
I didn't realize how big this map is.
Oh my God.
Oh, I'm free.
You know what, I'm just gonna, I'm just gonna wing it.
I don't think.
I don't think Matara's gonna have time to find anybody.
I don't know.
It's me.
I think that's gonna find that time.
It's gonna be me.
This is a wall.
If you make it up top here, you deserve to kill me.
Oh my god.
Is there an invisible wall?
The craziest map I've ever seen.
Yeah, there's an invisible wall on some of this.
I walked all the way over here.
It's me too.
I'm gonna try.
My amazing.
they're stressing me out please just hide in the game please
don't talk wait wait i'm a tiger you're open mic again if
you find me you deserve to kill me i'll just say that this
is diabolical i'm sorry there's just no way i'm pomney i'm
pomney your pomney yep wait oh i'm doing this with no
reference by the way so i don't know what what he actually
looks like I got kind of intimidated by the size of the map
and kind of just like meandered and then panicked oh shoot I
colored okay oh I'm stuck in the floor what the hell oh no
yeah yeah we all we all got stuck you kind of have to like
okay wow we oh I think it's gonna take you at least a minute
you make it to where I am you deserve to kill me wait I can
hear Matara I think oh wait I hear somebody else now I'm at
your feet I know it's not me okay I'm muted oh it's
infection dokey are you all the way at the top of the you
guys I wish I could see you right I feel so if you come all
the way up here you deserve to get it I'm just seeing i
think this map if you are able to walk all the way over to
the other side which i'm definitely am not in oh i'm
definitely at the far side of the map and you should walk
all the way over there yeah yeah i'm gonna come help you i'm
gonna come help you oh i just dropped oh wait wait can i
move hold on how do i move the amazingly fucking gigantic
circus i'm i don't know Can anybody see me flying in the
air?
No, wait, what?
Yes, I can.
And I can't run anymore.
You're fucking, you're styling in the air.
You're like catwalking.
Wow!
Yeah, you're flying.
For some reason, I can't get out.
I'm trying to get out to help me.
Don't kill me.
Look where I am.
Look where I am, though.
We can't look where you are.
It's infections.
No, I meant to be.
Oh, my God.
Why is there like a...
where would you go if you had control can you get that down
or you still that was i don't know i'm stuck in the air my
mental i can't believe if i hit one i'll get on stuff he
killed jacks he's dead again i think i think this map might
be made for a bigger group i didn't i didn't expect min to
start freaking flying
I think she's cheating guys.
I think she started dough clipping.
Hold on.
I can't help it.
Guys, I'm trying to move so you, I can, okay, I'm coming to
you.
I'm here.
I'm landed perfectly.
You're never gonna find me.
I'm trying to find you.
Are you jacks?
I think I found.
Wait, I'm floating now too.
Wait, I see her.
I'm gonna see how she's next to her.
You see?
Oh, it's so cute.
Maybe the map is so big that you just start going.
Okay, so she's right below me.
It's like an airplane.
Stuffy, come back here.
She's right below me.
We need you to shoot her.
Wait, listen.
Do you understand how long it's going to take me to walk all
the way over there?
Wait, how do I?
Wait, there's somebody on the couch.
Help me, help me.
Oh my God, it's amazing digital jacks.
I can't see you.
Get out of the air.
Stuffy, shoot her.
That was really just like the show.
Wait, is there someone actually on the couch?
Because I can't see them.
This map is fucked.
Oh, wait.
No, there is somebody on the couch.
There's multiple couches.
Guys, guys, guys.
Where Snuffy is.
Snuffy.
Yeah, no, I can't see anybody on that couch.
We should be.
Shooter, Snuffy.
We should be able to see other players.
Okay.
Oh, yeah.
Maybe because, yeah.
Maybe because I'm still hidden.
That'll be why.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where are you so tiny?
Why?
Oh, you're one of the people.
You're not a hunter.
Why are you so small?
Alright, so Min and I are stuck in this.
I can't, this is harder than looking on the map.
I can't shoot you.
You're too tiny.
I can't get you either.
So Min and I, we are sort of stuck in this wall area.
Talk about it.
Because I caught that.
You just don't look like you're having a fucking episode.
You're just shooting nothing.
the couch from where you are no i was watching you guys i
can see the cap from here like i can see down at all i can
spectate you but i can't spectate the hiders or see them the
invisible
i i don't i don't know if this is a very good map no no no
you have a hint i am not in this Sky so good luck.
I'm in the digital circus now.
I think I'm stuck.
Oh my god.
I can't get out of here.
I'm stuck.
I'm not.
I'm trying to learn these over again.
I'm jiggler and nibbler.
I don't think there was a nibbler.
What the fuck is a nibbler?
You don't remember?
I cried when he abstracted.
Me too, me too.
Oh shit.
Wait, what episode?
What did he abstract?
literally the pilot oh oh you have to you have to hit an
episode like the the yeah for true one yeah the tier one
supporters but there was a i think i know clips yeah i think
they're crazy i'm in the i'm in the background oh my god
where is she right where is this i see this tiny thing
glowing i can't even i can't there's no way i can find that
no i can't see that it's just Where are you, Lionel?
She's right here, right below me.
I'm slowly, oh my God.
Oh my God.
You're literally an aunt to me.
Your aunt to me.
It would have been slightly easier to find me if you know
you hadn't ended up in the sky.
Yeah, we were in the sky behind.
I ended up in a place with an invisible wall.
Wait, why am I like, I'm like floating, but also laying
down.
Oh my God, calm me.
I can see.
I'm calm me.
Yeah, and then Mint just floated up and slowly.
walked towards me in this fucking sky oh i figured out i'm
flying too now i finally figured it out wait how did you do
it the amazing digital flying machine dang damn that's how
she did it all right now okay now let me adjust everything
let me don't go i don't want to go back there please i will
do minecraft now i like the minecraft all right let me know
whenever you guys are ready and i'll press how do we know
how i'm ready though can you do you have any like no i have
no idea i saw people do the minecraft one on twitter so it
must be good yeah me too you've been training you've been
pre-training i haven't stolen a single hiding spot yet i
don't think all right maybe the balloon maybe i'm readying
up i'm starting you guys got downloading subscribing
subscribing oh sorry the error was processing wait oh yeah
oh you've made too many requests me too oh oh i didn't get
that oh i'll try again yeah me too you pressed it no way we
chose because you chose the digital circuits first wait wait
let's search it uh what was it It's just Minecraft.
Okay.
It's just Minecraft.
Keep refreshing.
It's just called Minecraft.
Oh, I got it.
I got it.
It says.
Oh, nice, nice.
It's the most popular one.
Oh, amazing.
I'm subscribing.
Don't forget to like and subscribe, everyone.
Yeah, hit the bell button and we want to get notifications.
Click the link in the spreadsheet.
description check out our merch guys buy our merch can we go
to like a restaurant place or something oh that's such a
great idea oh yeah and download a diner oh yeah yes nice
nice do you think they would have a pokemon map or a digimon
did you get the right map because it says you still haven't
done yeah oh yeah oh they're good it was just taking a
little while oh i see we should see if someone uploaded the
place the the fucking sim restaurant from when we did the
sloppy sisters stream i'm noticing everybody has likes above
their head but me i can i can give you a like just saying oh
don't do it don't give her a like just saying no she has to
earn it oh we're hunters oh that's what's going on i was
like did i mess up okay time to put on your put on your uh
scariest hunting outfit put on your hunting shoes this is
gonna be wait is this going to be really hard because we
have round brushes and everything here is fucking square no
no like all the actual pixels are it's all square no okay oh
like the minecraft no wait i am mistaken clearly yeah can
those the hunters are squares you're just round yeah oh too
yeah and i'm not gonna give you a like okay that's fine i'm
not begging for for likes at all I'll never okay I'm
painting I'm painting me too we're all locked in we're
locked in we're all serious gamers now Minecraft is very
serious
I like the Minecraft I am Steve chicken jockey I saw
references dude your references are out of control what are
you oh my god i still haven't got the chance of watching the
movies i've not watched the movie you haven't watched the
movie no sure chicken jockey i mean it took me like years to
actually play minecraft so i figured out plenty of time to
actually watch the movie yeah okay oh my god forgot about
this i forgot about painting my booty
for a second i'm so excited all right ladies one at a time
stop this is so cute okay stop wait this is actually the
cutest thing ever
oh why don't i do that why are we giggling what's going on
this is so i just looked at myself from a different angle
just read it i wouldn't have been able to do that my god
this is so cute feel few what what oh this map isn't that
big well it's because it's got a lot going on though i can't
tell if you miss hmm all right let's see if i can find the
others oh wait we're back in regular mode yeah yeah so we
can scout around solely up to us exit freaking wait how do i
get back to me wait oh there i am can you open the chest
she's just hiding in the chest imagine wait who's who's the
secret oh that was good though that was
what the is so what the are you sponge bob your sponge bob
i'm sponge bob everybody on this thing what the heck
ladies lady you just got so many points oh wait wait i can't
wait what the fuck is your spot I know.
Okay.
We all technically had the same idea, but like executed
differently.
I have no idea where you would even hide on this map to be.
It's so small.
Mimi was really tiny when I found her, so they're gonna be
tiny.
Wait, what was your spot?
I was in the fire.
Oh.
Oh, it doesn't move.
Woohoo.
Okay, I hear somebody clues, but I don't know.
I don't hear anybody.
I heard a whistle at my point in the mop.
Oh, yeah, we did it.
Oh, wait.
I don't know if right now all the points happen.
Oh, no.
Okay, they're welcome over there.
Chicken dinner.
Chicken jockey.
Ayla J can't see anybody.
This is crazy.
This is so difficult.
I love it.
I need to find one of you.
I feel like I'm straightening my eyes.
The sky is so freaking great.
I'm like, it's like, yeah, the brightness.
It's very bright.
Let's just say I love your hiding spot.
I can give you guys a hint that applies to all of us.
Uh-huh.
No.
Yeah, ruin your own game.
Step across your soul.
Fuck off.
If I give my hint, it's going to apply to all of you guys
because we all have the same idea.
We all have the same idea.
Well, if you find one, then it gives you a hint for
everybody else.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, you find one of us.
You might find the rest of us.
You find all of us.
I've been like, some of us are like right by dokey.
And we have no idea.
Yeah, you've run by dokey like I'm no idea.
What if you find one of us?
You'll find the rest of us.
how did you you found both of them so i have no idea what to
look for they're just hiding in these little like what do
they call it in video game debris where it's just you hide
no flat planes together so they're just hiding like the
grass like in between where there's like grass and fire
they're oh they're in the freaking bushes and stuff you only
found it because you you i blocked your path isn't it you
were just trying to no i literally looked down because i've
want me to look at you have not looked all the ups you have
not looked at all the ups you have not looked all the ups
yeah you have not that is a crazy map i don't think i don't
think you would have stopped me i don't know if that's a
thing i think i would have just walked over you i actually
don't know if the uh hiders have collision i think they do i
was like looking on roofs and stuff i don't even know where
i oh there i am did you know where i am What the heck?
I'm going to give a spot.
Yeah, man.
Yeah, man, you get an uptute now.
You get an uptute now.
Oh, that was really good too.
Nima, yours is great.
I told you, Nima.
Oh, wait.
I told you, Stuffy.
I told you, Yazzie, you find one of us.
You might find all of us.
Oh, that's the fire.
We can all do the same exact.
We did.
We have all hidden in intersections now.
Wait.
Wait, where did...
Wait, where's yours?
I'm in the tree.
She heard something.
Amitara actually walked around my tree at one point.
Amitara climbed up and was like, there's nobody up here.
There's no way.
Yeah.
Honestly, I couldn't see shit.
That's awesome.
What a great thought.
Go have a look.
I smooshed myself.
Yeah, I want to see.
I want to see.
Yeah, it's really good.
Yeah.
She went away.
Wait, how does this not count as like getting yourself
covered?
That's what I was thinking.
Like, I don't know.
She doesn't get mad at you if you like blend.
I guess.
It doesn't yell at me.
so yeah i think it's at the mod i'm not giving you an update
that was hard that was freaking hard yeah you ain't getting
up dude from me there all right you guys want to do bikini
bottom or the diner oh the diner oh the diner oh i didn't
subscribe give me let me subscribe to the crabby patty all
right let me find it
Alright, I subscribed to the diner.
Alright.
Base two hunters still?
Two hunters?
Somebody else.
Oh, I want to be a hunter.
Yeah.
Oh, I want a camp.
I haven't been a hunter in a while.
I'll hunt.
Oh, do you guys have time to go do hunting?
I think?
Actually, I don't know.
Nobody went on there, so I think it's true random now.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait, I can't.
I can't get you.
Yeah.
trips full where they may okay we'll see where it takes us
kind of hope i become a hunter wait can i put myself up here
oh wait oh wait you can move you can move oh wait yeah yeah
yeah all right who's gonna be everyone jumps out so it's
still random random random yeah oh it's me oh perfect dang
it it's me come on i got this i got this wait oh my gosh oh
my gosh let me trap pizza
What accident was that?
You want a big sausage pizza?
I can see the digital circus from here.
I actually can.
This is best of luck.
Where is it?
Haunted by the digital circus forever.
Oh, why are you painting us?
Actually, the diner's pretty small and the hiding places are
not plenty.
Wait, who is this guy?
Who's this guy standing here?
What is this?
That's weird.
I don't like that.
I don't like that either.
That freaks me out.
This is not ideal.
No, no, no.
This diner is...
Wait, there's just guys in here!
Ew!
And there's poop on the floor!
This place is disgusting!
It's actually quite a nasty diner, yeah.
Yeah!
I'm not so sure about this one.
I actually genuinely cannot find a place...
Oh, it's... I've got a place to hide.
We're gonna win this, Snuffy.
They have no confidence.
You girls are legit gonna win this This is actually kind of
tough, yeah.
Stop being Guy Fieri.
We're about to do some diners, drive-ins, and jives.
Yeah.
I don't know if he has a catchphrase, and I'm Guy Fieri.
I'm Guy Fieri.
That's his catchphrase just says his name.
Matara, look where I'm at.
I see, I see.
I just don't know where to go.
I know where to go.
come on in 17 seconds no i actually i don't know oh two
flavor town yeah the hiding spots suck yeah i see you lime
yeah all right here we come all right let's do a speed run
stuffy pop pop okay we're ready okay yeah this is this is
ready for a speed run i'm about to blow this stand What is
this?
Is this a guy or is this you guys?
Is this like a fake person?
Yeah, there's like Brad is like to throw me off or is this
one of you guys?
That's a fake person.
Wait, that's a fake one.
I thought that was a real one.
I was like, who's that over there?
It's just to throw us off.
How small do you think they are?
Well, they can't be that small.
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, I can't see the light is freaking blinding.
That's the thing we're sent to!
No, you'll see the hiding spots suck.
You poop.
You guys are the secrets.
You guys are the only place to hide.
I don't know, man.
That's it.
I think we're all in the bathroom.
Yes, there was the only place to hide.
I mean, what is that supposed to be for?
What about the person at the same?
God!
I don't think this one needed 200.
Yeah.
This is so small.
What do you mean?
I found...
Let's go.
This is what you guys were.
So, God.
Yeah, there was like nothing to hide in or against.
Come here.
I did all this guy for nothing.
No, no, no, you guys are very good.
Where's your pants?
Yeah, where's your pants, Katfieri?
I didn't have time to draw my pants.
They look so good.
I only knew that he wore a t-shirt.
I didn't know what the rest of them did.
No one ever sees the bottom.
He could be pantsless the whole time.
Oh, there is a digital circus.
I see it.
Yeah, in Flavor Town, you don't even need pants.
Oh, yeah, you see the digital circus over there.
Wait, wait, wait, where are we?
It's by the entrance of the...
What's that on the right you guys think is that Minecraft
kind of oh no wait that's the jump buckets it's another
digital circus oh jump buckets from the sponge bob all right
I'll do sponge bob next bikini bottom I think that has to be
a big map right that has to be a big one bobbing wait i've
already drew spongebob before oh man be be patrick yeah yeah
wait is it two hunters because we could be spongebob and
patrick oh that's true yeah that's so cute all right
download subscribing uh i'm subscribing subscribe subscribe
okay this This is called Sponch Seekers.
Sponch Seekers.
It's so intense.
Sponch Bob took 40 Benadryls.
What?
You guys know that one?
Nope.
That one's a little niche, maybe.
A little bit.
Me, me, niche.
Alright, I'm ready.
Yeah, we got this.
We got this.
We gotta ruin your bromance and see if I can get it.
Don't ruin your bromance.
Okay, good.
It was still us.
Pussycrap pizza.
Who do you want to be?
It's the pizza.
Why are these maps all in seemingly like...
I don't remember the characters very well.
I'll be Patrick.
I'll be SpongeBob.
It's like yellow and top blue on the bottom.
How bad could it be, right?
Yeah, exactly.
The colors are so harsh on these.
Wait, I'm Patrick.
Oh my god, where am I?
But never mind.
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, I can't see anything.
Am I being pink?
Am I turning pink?
No.
Can't wait, actually.
Wait, what color, what color are your shorts?
Are they black or blue?
They are the sewers.
I think they're blue.
In the bikini.
They're brown, they're brown.
They're brown?
Oh Jesus.
Oh my gosh, I don't know where to hide.
There's so many things here.
This map is, I didn't watch SpongeBob growing up because my
brother liked it, so thus I could not like it.
you know oh so true i got you all right colors i don't trust
myself but that's okay that is not the color that that i
think i have an idea i know where i want it it's like i ship
myself okay wait i'm going green wait wait i have an idea
this is this is not brown this is not even close to brown oh
my god i just have to make it i just had to make it over I
can paint this I can paint this when I'm there
I'm sure I don't know I don't know why the color would not
give me brown The horror version of SpongeBob.
I'm just committing now.
I'm Patrick.
I just realized they were way better places to hide.
Oh, yeah.
Look at us.
Oh, I'm still in.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
There are.
There might be.
Is anybody at my house?
I'm going to go check.
who's here patrick's home anybody walking around here
patrick's home look at what this is patrick not looking for
us patrick asmr role play actually great great nobody is
responding to me so i just feel like wait what the hell is
going on no this is patrick there's like pipes and stuff
what is all of this I can't respond.
I'd be such a huge fraud.
I didn't watch SpongeBob, so I don't know what anybody says.
Live.
You just have to be like, what's up, guy?
Oh, no, I know the narrator.
I know the narrator bit.
That's about it.
Oh, he likes burgers.
Patrick.
What was that?
Oh, wait.
You walked right past me.
You knew me was a burger on top of the burger cream.
You stepped on it.
That was...
I'm sorry.
I've never worked here.
I'm sorry, but I'm going...
This is Patrick.
That's how I bought nothing.
I'm not allowed in there, apparently.
What's wrong about Patrick?
Patrick's certain that I found plugged in.
Sponge boy be bald.
Maybe you should have been...
Maybe you should have been Mr. Graves.
Hink, hink, hink, hink, hink.
Hink, hink, hink.
oh i haven't here's a whistle somebody yet trick oh you
haven't seen me yet rotate i haven't seen enough yet m to w
it stands for wombo are you trying to be me well that's like
the worst that's the worst impression i've ever heard in my
entire life i'm just being you so that means you have a
worse impression
with pack species okay i would just like to say i didn't i
didn't get to see you know you guys my fellow hiders you're
not even trying what is this what is that what is this
protecting yourself from a freaking tornado like shut up i'm
gonna talk about your hiding spot
you're sick in the head not you that's it i'm gonna see
where you're hiding huh you're just gonna hide your hiding
spot yeah where are you hiding on each other's hiding spots
but nobody's been found yet we haven't found you guys oh
what the fuck i'm here for the whimsy my spot was whimsical
i like your shelter in place okay okay not gonna lie
snuffy's spot looks like she's Snuffy's spot looks like
she's like under arrest.
It's not.
It's literally.
She's not even a shot.
I didn't know what to do.
She looks like that song where the something was it.
But oh my god, what song was it where the guy was painting
against the wall?
Like what somebody you used to know.
You look like the somebody that used to know guy.
Somebody that used to know.
that I used to know.
Sorry, Limeo, I think I'm useless this map.
No, you're great.
You're just Patrick.
You're Patrick.
She's Patrick.
I'm Patrick.
Yeah, I'm enjoying the Patrick stuff, so that's cool.
Okay, I'll keep going.
Thank you.
I see a digital circus right next to us.
It's crazy that SpongeBob and the digital circus are set in
the same universe.
They are.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, back up?
Yeah, SpongeBob is also set in place in Missouri.
Yeah, SpongeBob's brain scan was from some random guy who
works at a minimum wage job.
That's why he's stuck in this eternal hell.
Wait, there is something weird up there.
What is up there?
You can see the amazing digital circuits from up here.
That's what we said.
Wait, what?
Why is SpongeBob mad?
He's having one too many crabby patties.
Like that's it, Mr. Crabs.
SpongeBob shoot his pants so he's upset.
I like to don't go to the crabby.
When I ship my crabs tomorrow.
I thought everyone was on my side.
When I hit and blew it in my pants.
Now she won't even spare a passing glance.
Oh, just because I...
poop my pants don't think where he came just to turn him
down but watch her day to a cloud and no girl look up guys
turn around you too turn around there's no way oh my god it
was so I was looking I was looking you know I dropped down
accidentally I had to climb back up that's horseshit I can't
get in there that's a that's a cheat we can't get in there
it's not a cheat it's not a I'm not allowed in.
Oh, you have to.
Yeah, you have to crowd.
Oh, I looked in there too.
I tried looking behind the door.
I'm sorry.
I'm so small.
I didn't realize that it was such an obstacle.
No, I thought it was just like a you're not allowed in
there, their spot.
But no, you have to kind of like wiggle your body in.
You do.
It's annoying.
Wait, Nimmies is so good, actually.
She looks just like a burger.
What angle?
I didn't want anything to say to someone.
I'm gonna give you an aeon.
I hate that answer.
It was so good.
Oh wait, I need to aeon Snuffy.
I have three seconds to aeon Snuffy.
No, no aeon.
No aeons.
I'm breaking into aeons.
Yeah.
Got all the aeons.
All right.
What's the next map?
Next map.
We have Overwatch.
Where's Wally?
Lush Caves.
Mirage from Counter Strike.
The Peak Airport.
Oh my god.
Luigi's Mansion, Peach's Castle, and Luigi's Mansion.
Luigi's Mansion.
Luigi's.
All right, do we want basic or infection for this one?
I don't know.
Basic, I think.
Basic was still 200.
It's fun.
Yeah.
200.
All right, I'm setting it up.
Now.
All right, download the maps.
I can probably do like two more rounds because I have to be
awake in seven hours for the detective.
Oh, yeah.
We should do another one LG then we could do one or two.
We should make next one LG I could do two more two more this
one and then a map that everyone really wants to do yeah
Yeah, we can do play again next time.
This has been fun.
Yeah, I'm so sorry.
I couldn't play for very long Oh, it's okay.
So much stuff going on this week.
No, sorry.
I came late.
No, it's okay We don't have to apologize for that girl.
Yeah, I mean whatever whatever you're recording that you
can't tell us I bet it's really I'm so sorry.
It's like 97% I bet it's so cool.
It is the coolest thing in the world I bet it's like really
cool guys
Okay, she's gonna be the flash Mataro are you gonna download
the longest 97% I don't know why it's like it's keeping me
at 98% look look look i'm not lying it's like dial up right
now yeah tell your mom to stop calling on the phone hang out
it's my roommate my roommate's streaming she's being a
streamer girl look go to go to a room and i'm like go to a
room and i'm streaming what's your
no for real okay hold on let me unsubscribe and then
subscribe again
subscribe from you and i won't subscribe again okay i'm
gonna i'm gonna unhit that notification bell i'm not gonna
like i'm not gonna subscribe i disliked
wait while you're doing that i'm gonna get some milk tea i
was gonna say water you're gonna activate lyme malicious
when you say that i have to get out of my i have to get out
of my okay what the cardboard for for hold on okay it's
actually lime are you getting your aligners out tomorrow yes
congratulations thank you thank you thank you thank you very
much i'm i'm excited but he said it'd be an hour and a half
because he wants to like fix some things like the aligners
like uh made the top of my tooth kind of jagged so he's like
i'm gonna just smooth it all out and do the composite and
then i'm gonna take the buttons off and then i'm gonna do
this and then i'm gonna do that i'm like okay and he was
like Okay, so an hour and a half.
I was like, oh, my God, please no.
Are these words people use when they talk about teeth?
Yeah, yeah.
I'm going to take your buttons off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They put like composite material on the front of your teeth
so that the aligners can like attach better.
So for like a year, even when my aligners are off when I'm
eating, I think so.
It's like they apply it directly to the surface of the teeth
and then it hardens and just attaches.
Oh.
Yeah.
That's hardcore.
yeah it's it's supposed to be subtle because it's like teeth
colored but obviously it just makes your teeth look really
knobbly because it's like you got bumps all over your teeth
so like this one time I met I met the I met the boyfriend of
a lady that I'd known for a while and he was very polite to
me and then afterwards apparently like when they went home
he said she was a nice girl but her teeth were really weird
the lady was like she's got liners in man her teeth aren't
actually shaped like that oh my god it makes you feel better
weird teeth are my fetish oh oh oh no okay what do i'm gonna
go mess up my teeth yeah yeah you can you you just go take
it off yourself you know you'll need a dentist for that
you're beautiful just start wrenching them off is that why
you wanted to be patrick and you wanted her to be sponge bob
your is that your rare pair very pretty teeth i believe your
teeth are very pretty okay girls i don't know why it's stuck
at 99 play this one without me should we do a different one
it like is 98 than 99 i'm sorry started i wonder if it's
already going in here if we if she's on a hat if she doesn't
have the map downloaded maybe she can get that was like
assets maybe i don't know why it did that it literally
stopped me at 99.
are you in oh but now it put me in as killers so maybe i am
yeah oh you're right oh yeah okay well we'll give it oh wow
this is so pixelated this is literally from the game cube
game yeah which one is this Luigi's mansion the first one
yeah the first Luigi's mansion what oh at least this will
match our wait why wait what's Oh, I think it's like a new
hunter.
It does not like something.
Oh, God.
It's like a new hunter because, uh, Matara can't load in.
We got it.
Oh, oh, oh.
Whoa.
It still shows that it's me.
Do it.
Got the hunter.
Oh, my God.
That was freaky.
Is Matara going to be selected again?
Yeah, it's not supposed to be, but it's me.
Oh, gosh.
We're going to be stuck in like a loop.
Like a time loop.
Yeah.
We just mentioned purgatory.
Wait, wait, wait.
We'll see if it re-selects after.
Maybe it'll download.
Oh, my God.
I don't even know where to hide.
I'm just going to paint myself then.
Yeah, me too.
Yeah, I think we're fine now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we're tired now.
It's not what Luigi looks like.
Like one of your French women.
Why don't you get the mustache so good?
I don't think his mustache looks like that, though, does it?
But it's a great mustache.
can you oh my god wait this is actually great oh wait i'm
very ambitious right now i would do something very ambitious
i think this is ingenious personally you know that doesn't
work either like how do you you can climb but how do you
lower yourself control oh oh that makes sense yeah oh my god
the little overalls thank you is that a hat i was You're
wearing on your head.
Yeah, it's my hat.
Yeah, good job.
This might work.
This might not work.
We'll see how it goes.
Does that mean I have to be Mario?
Yeah, you should be Mario.
Mario, Mario, Mario.
What's happening?
Oh, oh, it's doing it again.
It's doing it again.
Uh-oh.
Is it?
No.
Yeah.
Doing what?
It's the time.
Oh, wait.
No, no, no, no, it's not.
It's just time.
Yeah, it's just you're about to search for us.
I screwed up.
Oh, dear.
All right, this might be it.
Do you remember how to switch around so I can see my other
POV?
So I can paint on the other side.
You can use the middle mouse button to rotate.
Thank you.
Oh, wait, do you see anything?
I'm like super zoomed in on the map.
And then we go up.
But you still see it?
Like, you got it?
Yeah.
I'm just kind of like slowly in.
It's kind of weird.
I should have been in here.
Dang it.
Whatever.
such a cool map it is it's very not very creative but it's
okay i'm risking it all you make a map then i'm risking it
all with mine i got very i got very like indecisive yeah oh
oh donkeys yours is good yours is oh well kind of yeah yeah
yeah i know i just realized that's something oh it's not be
yours is oh it was good It was really good.
It was really good.
I almost didn't see you.
It was good.
Oh.
No.
I saw you did a double take.
I was about to run, too.
I know.
I think you might be good.
Every time it says that, we get shot.
Don't trust it.
Don't believe her.
Don't believe her lies.
Do not believe her lies.
I don't even know.
I know, like, oh, my.
I see you.
That's crazy.
Oh, wait.
I lied.
I told you.
Every time you say that, every time you say that, you get
it.
You get somebody killed.
He's like, Mint, don't look at my hiding place, please.
I'm sorry.
I didn't know.
You know what?
I think Mint's hiding place is really good, too, you guys.
I think...
I'm sorry.
Every single one of you.
I said your spots were good.
I think we haven't seen her yet because we haven't, um, like
haven't heard.
You haven't.
I didn't hear anything downstairs.
Woohoo.
I don't even know how you can get into this room.
Honestly.
Yeah, I've never, I didn't even know if these rooms existed.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Sometimes you do stuff.
You're like, wait a second.
There was a whole other room.
Yeah.
I love how the shadows and shading are just like, oh, wait,
I'm stuck.
Okay.
you just gotta find you just gotta find whatever room they
are in either of them wait either of them you just gotta
what you have fun either of them are you saying you're in
the main room i don't know what i'm saying i'm sick of
course mint lives after fucking all of us oh why are you
trying to why are you just a hater why are you a hater oh i
don't know every time you say wow that's a good hiding spot
we die no way i was trying to compliment you guys you you
were very sweet i appreciated the compliment as nimi spotted
my brains all over the ceiling yeah me too it helped me find
you i'm pretty yeah i'm praying on her downfall
There's going to be a whistle in eight seconds.
Yeah, yeah, give me a whistle.
Woo-hoo.
Hello, beautiful.
Hello.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait.
Oh, she didn't even double.
I don't know if she's in here.
She might be in the wall.
I don't think she's in here because we haven't seen the
score go up.
There must be, like, another way to get to that room.
No, I think it's bugged, actually.
If you remember she's a score go up, it must be so, like,
well, hidden that's, like, kind of tucked away.
You haven't seen her yet because, yeah, the score doesn't go
up.
go up i have oh is it actually like a cc thing well it
updates for them so it's not we get it in real time we get
in real time but the the seekers have to like update like
every couple of seconds oh i see now there's a little mento
you hear her she's somewhere she's somewhere what's through
the window what is that whoa probably the amazing digital
circus a digital circus where is she oh we got coins we saw
her no way yeah there's just no way i'm sorry but mint is
just she's a ghost she's actually just she's just watching
you from beyond the grave
i'm glad matara was the one that killed oh she's behind the
prince i even went back here oh my god no no we got that's a
crazy Snuffies is so good.
Snuffies is so good.
That is so...
How did you see that?
I was staring right at it.
It doesn't make it believable enough.
I glanced past it.
It's only because I came back for a second look.
I got an Aeon.
Thanks.
Yeah, because I believed in yours.
I appreciate that.
Wait, it won't let me like Snuffies, though.
Oh, you can only like one person.
Only one person.
Still Snuffies and i'm already giving stuffy the yep yep
thank you yeah i'm blowing up on on mecca chameleon holy
crap okay is this our last one then yeah next one this is
our next one's lg all right guys i'm gonna let's stop the
match dougie have you been the hunter like at all i've done
hunter i know right i've done hunter like two times i could
do it the third time yeah i'm ready i still sentence you to
100.
All right, there's Where's Wally, Overwatch, Lijiang, Lush
Caves, CSGO, Mirage, Peak Airport, Peach's Castle, Simpsons.
Which one should we play?
Which one does Chat want to see?
Overwatch, you're going to give me an advantage.
I remember everything from over.
Actually, Where's Wally could be crazy because of the amount
of stripes.
I actually want to see how that works out.
All right, let's see where's Wally.
Everything's just going to be fucking red and white stripes
everywhere two or two or one two high hunters or one for the
last one oh two two two yeah yeah all right two i'm
basically useless i'm so tired until your wait time all
right download time pray for the good thing about being sick
is then you don't get sick again for a while it's true
that's true i don't believe in that is it true is that true
we're now going into one season and i literally vulnerable
your immune system becomes vulnerable and you get
susceptible to more disease it's this map doesn't look like
a lot of stripes i'm gonna be yeah i was gonna say that did
not look very weird as wally to me wait this looks like
dukey actually obstacle course you guys are we sure we want
to do this one it's too late we only got a preview when we
click The next map will be LG.
Fair enough.
Okay.
And then it hits 5 a.m.
LG, LG.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think, okay, this one, you guys, this one I think is
really messed up.
I think you're literally supposed to, like, put yourself on
the portraits.
Yeah, so you're gonna...
I think so.
It's just pictures.
It'll be an exercise in art.
Yeah, yeah.
We're actually playing War's Wally.
Oh, never mind.
I'm a hunter.
All right, let's go.
War's Wally.
Oh, my God.
We're Wally Wally.
Oh boy.
You guys are excited about it.
It's gonna be terrible.
Wait, I just fell off the map you guys.
Wow.
What?
I'm not.
Yeah, you come back.
Okay.
Wait, can we not roll over there then?
Oh, no.
You guys selected Wally.
I gave you a choice.
Well, we might get to see you before you picked.
I might have found an awesome spot.
Wait, how do you even get to the to the posters?
You have to jump in a crate.
You really can't.
It's too big.
This map is too big.
Is that good for you guys?
What is this?
You have to like make a leap of faith.
There's no way.
I know.
It's actually kind of terrible.
There's no way.
Wait, there's a wall.
You can't even get to them.
What is this?
I don't know.
It's just for those who like the theme of Waldo.
Maybe.
you know yeah look at waldo are you supposed to just play
the game with friends you also know that the the map was
made by someone british because because it's where's wally
yeah where's wally i was when you said wally i was like my
people my people where's waldo is wally here dude this is
insane i'm gonna wait are you guys doing a face dokey i just
went full like red I'm you it's an attempt you know I'm
really tired I've been I've been like for a while stuffy
stuff I don't know whoa oh my tarot ears is pretty good oh
no wait I shouldn't say that should I yeah the mini
compliment curse I'm sorry what the fuck what the hell is
wrong with you guys Oh my god.
What the fuck is this?
What do you mean?
We're actually on these walls though right now.
Leave them.
I don't even know if you guys are actually on the painting
too.
Oh my god, we're parkouring.
Oh, I fell off the bat.
I don't know if any of us are on the painting because it's
impossible to get over there.
Yeah.
I got stuck.
Well, I guess I could have, you know, I don't know.
Damn, Mimi, you are crazy.
I know.
I think they're gonna see me though.
I wonder if you guys are not hiding.
You're not even on the painting, right?
No.
Oh, she might be.
Don't say that.
She might be.
Oh, I muted an off angle from over here if you see it.
Oh, no.
It offset you.
Oh, my gosh, mint.
What are you doing?
I never got to find you.
I got stuck here.
That's impossible!
I was trying to go to...
Is Mint no clipping?
Mint is no clipped through the world.
Oh.
I was trying to get to a painting and I got stuck.
Wait, I can't even find her.
Hold on, hold on.
Yeah, go through the... No, no, no, no.
Don't tell me.
Well, she's near... I don't think this is a serious
competitive map if that helps.
Alright, this is Roblox.
What are you talking about?
all right so mint is stuck somewhere so that's the old mint
and she's near a painting so that's all we need to know i'm
stuck by a painting she's stuck by a painting that's all the
hints we get somebody is not somebody is cheesy well i fell
down oh i fell off i saw your little nameplate of flying
through the world and something all right
Oh, Snuffy did the tactical change.
I see it.
The tactical change.
Wait, did you?
These are great, you girl.
Oh, yes, yes, good.
These are really good.
I'm very happy.
Snuffy's playing the game.
Oh, he's playing the wind.
That's all I can do.
This is all I can do.
Oh, I need our whistle somewhere.
Don't fall off the world.
Don't fall off the world, Toki Bird.
I kept there's an invisible while here.
So I don't...
Oh, there's a fire.
That's where I fell.
Did you just fall off again?
I guess there isn't a divisible wall there.
Excuse me, my partner keeps throwing herself off the map.
Maybe I need to go back to Snuffy because she's like crazy.
I'm not.
Snuffy is the TV, the television program.
Oh yeah.
You want to be watching.
Yeah, Snuffy, Snuffy Graham.
All channels.
on the tv any channel oh they're gonna get her snow no
there's no way they could get me dude no i don't have faith
in me because you're gonna keep oh my god it's because
you're gonna keep snake wow great spot and then they're
gonna find her when you say that why does like the giant
waldo say sign say where's waldo at home what's over there
do you see a bunch of like really he decided not to put on
the map so that's the digital circus that's it oh oh do we
have another digital circus oh yeah this is waldo at home at
the very bottom at the bottom oh yeah oh my god i'm back in
the hunter screen that's kind of crazy where are you leaving
your back are you like get you then no no no i'm where i'm
i'm free cameraing and i'm just looking around yeah this map
is big enough that i can't really hear where the whistle's
coming from i heard it vaguely it was like near me for a
second but that for but then i fell off the map so i didn't
know where the positioning was again i i lost control of my
life oh my god snuffy be careful snuffy be careful how do
you feel right now mint how do you feel are you feeling the
pressure as if oh it's close there's no that's good
Yeah, the weight of the pressure.
Did you do that?
Sabotage?
Yeah, the weight of the pressure.
Oh, I'm off the map again.
I watched it drop.
So dope.
I don't know where I'm in.
Oh, man.
I could not get up anymore for some reason.
Oh, I'm just stuck down here.
Welcome to Stocksville.
Yeah.
I have like actually gotten some stuck down here i can't
climb this i don't know why where the can i jump to here
okay i need to know where no clip dude oh my computer's
crashing oh gosh oh she crashes before we're finding it what
where was she where is she look at her right here come here
come here where is she i fell inside the little the little
thingies trying to get to the page though we can't even i
can't even
crazy i was whenever you guys would come around she's rotate
to the other side yes she would she just went to while i was
get rotated get rotated get rotated i lost my sanity in the
where's wally world That's my t-shirt.
I should have wrote that on my little guy.
I think we do one more LG because that map was based on one
final truth.
Can we just do one of the base maps?
Yeah, we do.
We tend to be more balanced, I feel like.
All right.
The hide and seek mansion, sewers, the back rooms, indoor
country, penguin hotels, sugar land, or Osaka?
Did we do indoor country?
What is that?
Yeah, we did.
Oh, that was the farm one.
that far yeah i don't mind i'm good with any all right we'll
do i'm good with any and we do random it'll pick the one the
dlc maps too so it'll be like where's waldo again go pick
your basic digital circus again oh no please no not the
digital circus all right indoor country i started who wants
to be the see look at me you guys i'm i'm i have the perfect
we can all get inside for I'm like, make it random, make it
random.
I'll stay out of it because I was at a secret already.
Okay.
Oh my God.
Your car is stuffy.
I tried to be white because it is still white.
Me and Mint, let's go.
I know what I want to do.
This is, this was my trauma.
Wow.
What the fuck?
Wait, wait, wait, Matara.
You write HA and I write GS.
H-O.
Wait, I got an idea.
This has the same energy as like a T-T-I-C.
Hold on, do we have to set?
A T-T-I-C.
A T-I-C.
I'm gonna write Attic.
Okay, never mind.
Hold on.
No, I wrote Ha.
Okay, okay, hold on.
I'll do it in my colors.
How do I?
Yeah.
Yeah, and then I'll write ha in the front as well Okay,
yeah, okay good good.
And I'll write ha at the top of my head.
Are you guys hags?
Are you?
Yeah, you will join us one day.
Okay.
No, I'll write ha on my shoulders as well Well, Doki, if you
never join us in hagnum, that means I'm not good That means
you're not good.
What does that even mean?
That means, uh, yeah, exactly.
Oh Yeah I thought you meant like a skill issue.
Like you're not good.
Oh,
and a big butt.
Oh, nice.
Yeah, yeah.
Make a big butt for you too.
Oh, I can't, how do I, I got it as well.
It looked okay, but I think actually this was a mistake long
term.
The game or the, the, the.
no to what i've chosen here mm-hmm me too honestly me too
yeah same same i believe i was like yeah this is gonna be
good oh no oh no oh dear let's go hey
you the rubber rabbits over there jesus are you hating are
you hating no of course not of course not i love them she's
a hater she's a who are we rub rub rabbits it's like the
sega property yeah where you do like a sequence of like
absolutely fucking insane minigames while it does like this
really ridiculous penis music soundtrack those white rabbits
are singing penis music yeah come on live i would never do
that i would never do that i would never do that snuff me
snuffing me i i i couldn't i i broke under pressure i didn't
know where to go wait what what are you sometimes hiding in
plain sight is the best thing to do agreed agreed especially
when i'm sick as a dog and i can't They are just a dog.
Snuffy's really good.
That's a really good spot.
Is she moving?
Is she...
I'm going to go look for Snuffy.
Sorry.
It's great.
They'll never know.
No!
Oh.
i couldn't i couldn't get out of spectator i was gonna do my
parkour i was gonna go i was stuck in spectator i'm stuck
serves you right oh this is where i was before i crashed
okay so there's one of them here i got a folk oh my god i
can't see anything they all started looking up my strats
stop working yeah everybody started looking up how funny are
you it's hilarious i will say it's pretty funny yeah it's
pretty funny wait i like your hiding and it was good they
were already knocked over i know i asked the same stuff i
would say somebody that i used to know but
Did Snuffy DC?
My Snuffy!
Oh no!
She DC'd!
Our spot was up!
Oh, I can't.
It won't let me get up.
Yeah.
Don't worry, you guys will see.
I'm Snuffy, you DC'd.
We'll see Snuffy.
Oh, bye!
I'm D.C.
I'm only able to crawl.
It's all up to you.
Okay, can you press crouch?
Press climb or crouch or something?
Yeah, I did.
It says I don't have enough space to get up.
Wait, I think if you like crawl more.
you'll be able to see it it's okay like banned for my funny
yeah i saw your spy was like take my game seriously i like i
keep hearing it i keep hearing there's no way are you under
here there's no way there's no way wait what was your spot
then snuffy it was when the maybe you guys can still see no
it's gone it's gone when when the when the game ends you'll
see it because it'll still have a record of her spot okay
good yeah yeah there's like somebody here but I'm so like
I'm getting so congested oh my god you guys see me on the
ceiling perfectly blending in but yeah the ceiling tactics
are old news yeah they are you got you got to get with the
times no my god the meta changed there was a new patch no
the meta changed okay okay it's like here i heard the oh my
god no that was really good oh literally it's literally a
meta literally under you no no no wait i'm stuck Oh, my God.
Wow.
That was good.
I was never going to find you.
Godly gaming.
All right.
Last one.
The only thing that gave you away is that it kept, like,
wooing.
So I was like, okay, she's got to be somewhere.
Oh, the other one is, like, we're here.
Is it here?
Oh, well.
You thought I heard the little hole like this way.
Do it again.
Woo-hoo.
Woo-hoo for me.
for me shopping oh no way i didn't see you run i couldn't
get out of the wall i couldn't get out of the wall is it
gonna show wait oh it's right here left left side oh you
don't have the record anymore oh no it's not okay it's on
one of the it's the horses it was very good yeah it was
really good we'll send a screenshot wait wait someone can
send a screenshot of it she gave the horse an extra leg oh i
wasn't gonna say if it's a little pp poo-poo kind of fun it
looks like my whole steam like died oh my god you got back i
knew you were hacking i knew you were chicken he got back
then yeah what the heck oh man i'm so bummed what an
anticlimactic end i was so make you guys laugh so bad don't
worry don't worry we laughed nimi lam and i laughed i i
thought it was i laughed we got we got to see it yeah i'm
laughing wait wait someone can screenshot wait stuffy
screenshot from your bot okay yeah it is set in the group
chat really quick yeah you guys have to see it it was crazy
that i i did not realize you would last that long also i do
not know how but you guys also walked around me so much and
i I'm just going to say that we couldn't have been more.
I was even looking at the horses so much.
I don't know.
Maybe nothing looks normal, you know?
Sometimes horses, they just, you know.
I once.
They just, you know.
Actually, maybe I shouldn't say this story.
Wait, wait.
I'm so curious.
I'm so sorry.
It was like one of those like outback restaurants that have,
it had like a little bowl outside of it and i would always
if it was like anatomically correct bowl and i would look at
it and i'd be like wow they really made it so uh-huh i don't
know is that correct i don't know
wait they had a what outside of it it was like a bowl statue
but they made it really like oh oh yeah okay we had big
bowls you know i see i see i see this is this is my
beautiful master feet oh my gosh that angle what i would
have never seen that it's crazy honestly it looks like a
tail it looks like a bit like the front side of it oh those
are the teeth i mean sorry not the
What kind of are the bull anatomically correct bull?
What kind of horse peepees are you looking at?
I didn't mean to say the teeth.
Hey, I'm not judging, obviously.
Okay, I don't even know if I can show this on stream, but I
did anyway.
I showed it on stream.
It was on the screen, man.
It was on the screen.
Wait, I'll show the one.
I'll show the one that is coming.
I didn't see it.
This is a disgusting angle.
It looks like a tail, though, from the back.
Sometimes you girls invented these angles.
Like, Doki on the chum bucket was crazy.
Yeah, that worked.
Yeah.
I even fell down from the chum.
I fell down from the hat.
I need to go back up.
I was like, oh, shit.
there he is there she is i want to know how long she would
have lasted too i can't believe my whole i know you're gonna
whistle like that looking like that
i think steam might be having problems because i just got a
cloud error as soon as i exited the game so i think there's
some stuff we we all got backbend for oh no we're gaining
too hard degeneracy maybe what are these maps i downloaded
just or malware actually um i downloaded like 20 waldo world
was actually like a trojan horse dude yeah that was terrible
if we could actually get on the painting that would have
been fun i know you're trying to get to the painting yeah
around steve maintenance chat isn't it ironic that did they
delay it just to impact the sloppy people they're like oh
they're like they're pushing this stream we'll push our
steam maintenance oh they heard us come offline it'll be
funny but thank you very much for inviting yeah i had fun
i'm sorry you can't wait for this one but can we do it again
when i'm awake we'll get an even bigger group and then we'll
we can replay digital circus with No!
No!
Not there!
We're going to have to actually look up some good maps.
I'm going to abstract.
I'm going to abstract out.
But yeah, I'm down to get do another collab of this game.
There's so many maps too.
So many things we do.
GG's everyone.
Thanks Doki for organizing.
Thanks for all coming, honey.
Thank you all coming.
GG.
Bye-bye.
Yeah.
Good night.
Bye.
That was fun.
I had so much fun playing.
Oh my gosh.
I can't believe the ceiling metal died out.
it started and died out on the same day i thought i was so
smart i was like no one's gonna look up no one's gonna look
up a second time no one's gonna look up a third time like
what the fuck looks up
what they learned i've like i've like i've like trained them
to look up but he thank you keep doing i just felt like i
was like there's no way they'll do it a third there's no way
they patched it so quick I talked I taught them how to look
up but I'm I was real happy with this with this collab it
was really fun really great time with all the girls um it
was really funny just like all the different hiding spots
everyone did uh it gets funny it gets funnier every time
guys you I still can't believe I live with the I can't
believe I fell down and then climb back up on the chum
bucket and I and I live through it You know, it's I'm trying
to be unpredictable.
There'll be like there's no way Doki would do it a third
time, right?
There's no way.
I also can't believe like we didn't have an alert We didn't
have an alert thing for I don't know how many streams
because I forgot I forgot like I accidentally overrope
Because I overwrote my alert with Matara's Fugi.
I don't even know when that happened.
I don't even know when.
It has to be like our last collab or some shit.
Like literally like three weeks ago.
And then we never had alerts on.
And we nobody noticed.
But gee, geez.
I had a great time hanging out with everybody.
I'm glad to finally be able to play Metsha Chameleon.
Because I keep seeing all these.
funny videos about it so i had a great time any guys i'm
gonna call it here uh as always everybody stay hydrated
posture check get up and around to get that blood flowing
and you said for me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll
see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye